You're welcome.
Good.
Hey,
freak pitchers.
That's how you started off with podcasts.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is a lot of people out there doing it wrong.
Um,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
Squarespace.
Uh,
we've had Squarespace as a sponsor of our podcast for several months now.
And um,
we've been really happy with the feedback that we've gotten from you people
who've actually tried it and used it.
It's one of the easiest ways you could ever make a website.
A dummy like myself could put this shit together if you have never heard of it.
The way Squarespace is set up is it's the old days.
You used to have to either learn html or you'd have to learn a program that
allows you to create your own website.
Very complicated.
But Squarespace makes it ridiculously easy and they have it set up so you could
try it out without entering your credit card information.
That's how confident they are of their product.
If you go there,
just try it out.
Build yourself a little snazzy website and you go,
you know what?
This is pretty bad ass.
I'm going to,
I'm going to go with this.
Then you use your credit card information and if you use the code Joe,
and then the number eight,
all one word,
Joe Eight,
if you do that,
they will give you 10% off your first purchase on new accounts,
including monthly and annual plans.
So go check it out.
It's a pretty sweet sight.
Um,
it's so easy to do that.
Brian has made probably like 10 websites while we've been doing this pop up
podcast.
We will over the course of like,
Squarespace is a sponsor.
How many websites have you done?
Yeah,
a lot.
I mean,
it's so fast.
It's like,
not even like,
I don't even like,
that's like just doing whatever and like throwing trash away.
And the thing is they look good.
They look like a website.
You would pay someone to do,
they look as good as my website.
I paid somebody to do my website,
my next website I'm going to fucking do myself.
That's how gangster I am a squarespace.com.
The code again is Joe and the number eight.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com uh,
if you,
uh,
have been,
waiting for the gorilla kettle bells,
they're out now.
It's it,
it's official and they look fucking awesome.
It's 72 pounds.
And this was a difficult thing to design because not only did we have to make
sure that it looked cool and it looks awesome.
The,
uh,
the artwork is fantastic.
I will have to get the artist's name from Aubrey and credit them because they
did an amazing job on both the chimp and the gorilla.
And look,
it's just,
it makes kettlebells extra fun.
That's what it does to me.
I view the chimp is if it was attempting to bite my penis off,
that's how I see the chimp,
the chimp phase and the gorilla is about to steal your soul.
That's what it looks like to me.
72 pounds.
And um,
if you've never worked out with kettlebells before,
it's the best way you can get your full body to work as one strong unit with
weightlifting,
if that makes any sense.
For functional strength for,
for whether it translates into athletics or just being able to actually pick
things up and move things around.
Having a strong body.
Kettlebells are amazing.
Um,
we have a video on,
uh,
on at.com called the extreme kettlebell cardio workout by Keith Webber.
Um,
it's an amazing workout and if you can do that with the 72 pound gorilla kettle
bell,
you're a fucking beast.
I can't,
I almost throw up when I use a 35 powder.
It's a brutal workout.
So we saw all of that kind of shit it on it.
Um,
strength efficient conditioning equipment,
including battle ropes and weight vests and Macy's.
And contrary to popular belief,
this is an armor and a,
these aren't weapons.
Okay.
I know it looks like we're trying to formulate an army,
selling them brain pills and cordyceps mushroom supplements and getting them to
think about chimpanzees.
Biting your Dick off,
but no one's trying to plan any ideas,
folks.
Okay.
These are just,
this is just to work out,
get yourself an ab wheel,
do some yoga by some Himalayan sea salt and go fuck yourself.
Okay.
Use the code name,
Rogan and you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Dan Carlin's here for round dose and when we're fixing to make shit happen,
boom
experience Joe Rogan podcast.
Powerful Dan Carlin.
We had,
we couldn't start this podcast quick enough because we were podcasting before.
The POCs are talking before it happens.
It's going to be back in the house of Brogan.
That's good.
It'd be happy back sir.
Appreciate it very much.
But yeah,
we,
we literally had to say stop,
stop,
stop.
There's so much that we were talking about from Anthony Wiener to how much of it
needs to be in the podcast.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
The folly of man,
you know,
it's Oh Anthony wiener to the folly of man.
Well it is the folly of man.
He is.
Anthony Wiener is the folly of man.
Who was the reason why we all recognize with him as we all know,
that could've been us.
Okay.
If you were that guy live in that life thinking that way for that long,
doing the and making the decisions he made,
he,
that guy got on the path.
It
doesn't focus on the drives me crazy.
Can I just,
sure.
The reporters as an old reporter,
the reporter should ask the question this way.
Forget about the specific salacious thing that we're having so much fun with,
which is all they focus on and ask this here is a guy that knows what's out
there.
Right?
Decides I'm going to run again,
knowing that what's out there is out there and that what's out there will be
discovered again and that he will be in the position he's in now.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay,
so the guy who does it any way,
I'm now going,
this is the guy who's working on nuclear nonproliferation.
This is the guy who,
I mean this is a judgement question where you go,
if a guy knows I'm going to put myself into position 100% absolutely where I'm
going to get whacked again.
I mean I just,
I suffered through all that.
I went to marriage counseling.
I'm going to get to do it all again.
100% chance of that and I'm going to run anyway.
I don't care about the issue he got zapped with.
I'm cared about all the other issues that that same judgment is being applied
to.
Yeah.
He's obviously crazy except that he's not the only one.
What I thought about with Clinton where you go,
okay,
I don't mind the Lewinsky thing.
I mind that a guy smart as that man is,
has to know it's going to come out and it has to still go through with it and I,
that's the part I can't fat.
Well,
I think the type of person that wants to be mayor in the first place,
the type of person,
okay,
I'm with you on that.
There's this insane belief in yourself.
Something weird already.
What's the old line if you want to be a politician or you should be disqualified
for that desire.
Yeah,
that's,
I've echoed that sentiment without even knowing.
It was a quote I always said,
no one should be president that wants to be pressed.
I had somebody tell me the same thing about police officers and he was a police
officer.
Say if you decided,
you know what I want to do,
I'm going to go tackle people and I want to point the gun at people and I want
to,
if you want to get cats out of trees,
you should be a police officer.
You know these other things,
the adrenaline pumping things sound good to you.
I want you to take a lot of big battery of tests first and make sure
everything's cool.
That's such an important point,
man.
I mean,
isn't that what we wound up with that Christopher dormer guy,
the crazy guy that got fired as a cop and went on a rampage just started killing
cops and ally?
Well,
I had,
I had a buddy who,
who,
and he was a wild man.
I mean he was just not the kind of guy you wanted to even turn your back on when
you went out at night with each.
And he went into the police academies,
graduated second in his class or whatever and then left and said,
those people are crazy.
And they just see this course.
But you know,
I know a lot of police officers,
they're wonderful guys.
My point is is that it's,
it's an interesting line of work.
Have you ever seen the different police videos that they show around the country
and in some of these towns,
you know,
the way that they sell being a police officer,
it looks like Andy Griffith and you're like,
that's exactly the kind of guy I want to apply for the job.
And another ones,
they're showing you in the armored vehicles pulling up with the arm and you're
going,
no,
no.
Someone that likes that ad and the response to that ad,
it should be instantly disqualified from wanting to be one.
Well,
you know,
it's,
you're,
you are a professional conflict person.
That's right.
That that becomes the real issue because most of us try very hard to avoid
conflict because the stress of conflict is really unhealthy.
Yes.
And dangerous.
Dangerous.
It's freaky.
Make bad choices.
You know,
people don't realize like how stressful life or death situations can be and
someone who does that professionally is constantly in life or death situations.
That's a professional conflict person.
It's an incredibly difficult job.
Crazy people all the time.
I mean,
let's realize how tough that job is.
But if you're sitting at home going,
what am I going to do for a job?
And you see a guy in armor and he's rolling on the ground and that looks good to
you.
Join the army,
you know,
there's other places for you.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's almost like applying or a attaching to a mindset.
You know,
the idea of,
uh,
getting someone who would be willing to do the job in like a very enlightened
way is almost impossible to find because even if they were like this,
you know,
Depok shopper type
cat who with a gun that was just trying to calm everyone with the yoga between
outings and they've be,
we are experiencing this objective.
Sergeant Gandhi.
I think after a while your own self preservation instincts would kick in if you
were in a suitably bad neighborhood.
Gallows humor and everything.
I mean,
we were,
we reporters used to be able to joke with the cops,
well,
because you're out at two in the morning.
It's a murder scene and there's some twisted,
weird,
I mean,
I remember going to a murder scene that was really horrible,
but there were a few twisted aspects that are kind of funny in a Quentin
Tarantino dark way and they know they can joke with you about it even though
it's a tragedy and they're upset about it.
Right.
It's almost a coping mechanism.
You know,
the old line is,
and there's no question that most police officers are just fine and we never
hear about the Sergeant Gandhi on Youtube or you know what I mean?
So,
but they're very careful about who enters their ranks for a reason.
So why would you put out a video showing all the adrenaline pumping things,
you know,
when you're trying to recruit these people who aren't going to go crazy when you
have a police shooting situation.
You know,
recruiting in and of itself is very strange.
It's very strange that you're allowed to make this romantic depiction,
essentially manipulating someone's ideas of what it would be like to be a police
officer.
And that's what you're doing dealing with homeless people on the street with
with,
yeah,
exactly.
Because that's most of your job or an army commercial where your truck runs over
an IED and you know it gets launched in the air.
Most of your friends do.
We don't even show that on the recruiting videos.
Well,
that's,
it's very strange that it's come to that.
It's very strange that we're in this weird situation where we've somehow or
another agreed that it's okay to withhold and not share information.
Especially information about really pertinent news,
like the war is a very important subject,
but all you ever get is you occasionally get a few numbers with letters behind
them and that's what represents the dead.
You get that in the news,
you get that on the newspapers.
It's very rare.
There's stories on CNN or anything about the toll,
who's dying,
who their families are,
how they're coping with,
what are their thoughts on it.
You have to know though that that is all by design.
That's not excellent,
but here's the,
here's the,
I had this conversation with somebody just the other day where I said,
look,
the stuff is out there.
I mean this is the Internet age.
There are a camera phones.
If you want to go see what the war is really like go online and start searching.
And you will see the problem is,
is if you are the one looking for it,
you are not the one who has to see it.
Well,
right.
The old,
the old three network thing was,
you know,
you're eating dinner and the Vietnam War intrudes in your living room with death
and violence and Gore and all of a sudden you're like,
wow,
look at what war really looks like.
The guys who are looking at war to see what it really looks like.
One might be liking it and two,
they,
they're not the ones you have to educate.
It's,
it's Middle America and you know,
Mr and Mrs. Jones who need to see it and don't want to look at it.
Yeah.
And want to be fed a Sandra Bullock movie and we want to be speeding other
things.
You know,
life is happening,
man.
Life is happening.
That's right.
And who has time?
Yeah.
It's,
it's just,
uh,
it's,
it's a weird admission.
You know,
that that's
where we're at when the,
you know,
the world we live,
we want to look at it one way,
but it's like really clearly not the way we want to look at it.
And when you see these sort of romantic depiction,
it's like you're seeing the one for the marines,
those videos where they,
they're,
they're showing you like a recruitment video and the guy's got a sword spoil.
Yeah.
And they're doing in mixed martial arts from each other and each chair flying
over this obstacle course,
like a bad ass.
Yeah.
And you're like,
what does any of that have to do with war?
You didn't shoot anybody there.
No one piloted a drone in that commercial.
You pulled out a sword and you guys really,
here's the scary thing,
man,
to take it to the police video we had imagined showing and marine recruitment
video where you're showing pump in 20 bullets into a body that's exploding it
buddy.
And the guy goes,
yeah,
that's what I've been waiting to do this.
I mean you have the same problem.
I mean,
you know,
not sure you want those guys joined the [inaudible].
Well they're going to probably join anyway,
but you're absolutely right.
Yeah.
What's the solution there?
Because he want really good killers.
If you want really good killers,
you know you've got to make sure they're trained correctly.
Getting instead of the man,
I don't think we have to do any better.
They're really good.
Let's not,
let's not minimize.
No doubt.
Well I'm saying if you're trying to recruit them though,
what is the way you would go about doing it?
They go to e three man,
they have their own video game and the army has one really cool first person
shooter and they go there with these.
Yeah,
they do and they did that on purpose tents and like the kids are like,
wow,
this is a cool video game.
Is this what it's really like?
You know what they used to do though?
Back in my day.
I remembered them at the high school that's about three miles from here,
which is where I went to high school.
Then landing the brand new,
never before seen a patchy helicopter when it was brand new,
right on our high school football field and the whole school gets to go out
there and I remember watching the guy in the Apache showing us how the guns were
attached to his helmet and if he turned his head to the left,
the guns in front of the Apache Wood and oh look how cool this is.
I moved my head to the left of these two machine guns.
Go to the,
to the look,
I can win and met your teacher.
You know,
I mean it was just,
it was that the 1982 version,
way better than that.
Atari 7,200 you know,
think about that.
Yeah,
it is pretty crazy.
If you think,
think about the idea that they're recruiting by using video games and that
eventually those are skills that are going to translate throughout the look.
Let's make no mistake about it.
Whoever's the first to get a robot army of bulletproof tightener on the way
there right now,
man,
we got,
yeah,
I mean for real.
We're real close to being able to do that.
We already have flying ones.
They're walking ones.
Have you seen these walking robots that are developing?
Wait until this shit.
Wait til it's our Marone's taking wait til it's our drones taken out their
drones.
I mean once you get to that point where the first thing you do is establish
drone supremacists before you,
you know,
send the troops on the ground.
We have a war in the sky with robots,
North Korea,
Korea already has human robots in some ways,
you know,
they would pretty much do anything a robot,
but they feel and they mainly are video game trained youth will save the
country.
North Korea is like the last country left that rocking like all full on military
dictatorship with nuclear weapons right in front of the world.
Yeah.
But you know what's funny is that they're like an egg.
They're putting this thing,
they appear to be strong on the outside,
but North Korea would go down as quickly as Iraqi.
They have no money and plus they just don't,
I mean it's high tech versus low tech.
A lot of,
you know,
I look at sometimes the North Korea and the publish how many tanks they have and
I mean,
but you look at the details of it and the tanks alone,
1950s vintage,
I mean they,
they move one foot and they'd be gone.
I mean,
that's what people don't understand that the patches would shoot them over the
skyline.
They wouldn't even see anything.
The night vision would destroy everything.
I mean,
it would be like third world.
it's nothing you have,
they have these fucking ships now,
these battleships,
they launched these fighter jets off of and they're,
they're like cities.
It's a God damn city that's made a metal that floats outside of your town and
when you fuck up,
it's just there's,
they can see everything those night vision things when they see,
see what the side,
it's not,
the North Korea thing is a little weird because they're within artillery range
of a very large city soul,
which changes everything because you know,
they say,
okay,
yes you can beat us in one second,
but how many people in Seoul,
how much,
how many buildings can be knocked down before you destroy us?
But I think they have all those sites targeted from years of observation and you
know,
I'd be,
can you imagine if that had happened to the United States during the civil war?
If we became a north and South America like that or north and south United
States around there where we had like literally people that look just like us,
we're from our lineage.
The North would be like Canada now.
The south would be like the south,
it'd be this,
you know,
you wouldn't have slavery anymore.
I don't think.
I mean,
I think,
I think you would have eased out of that and you would,
you would have to similar countries that may be played in a football super bowl.
I mean,
you'd have the,
the union versus the confederate team.
You know,
it'd be interesting,
I'd love,
I've always loved to have this idea.
Do you remember back to the future of the movies?
I always loved to this idea.
I'd love to be able to program in an alternative reality and just see what
happened.
If you,
Hitler wins the Second World War,
the north and south and he just,
and you watch the different development go off into the distance and how many
things change,
right?
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's fascinating when you think of what could have,
I mean,
people,
the common phrase,
you know,
hey,
we would all be speaking German.
You know,
what would have happened if they discovered the nuclear bomb before it was what
could have happened and if to Japan dropped it on us before we could drop it on
them.
It's a,
those,
those moments in history are very strange,
aren't they have these pivotal moments where everything changes?
Well we,
and you know,
we talk about that.
Let me,
for us,
and I don't think we quite formulated how different this is,
but nine 11 is that kind of a,
we lived through a moment that 200 years from now they will study as a pivotal
moment in world history.
One of these things where it took less than 24 hours to happen and,
and the,
and somebody wrote me a letter saying,
I don't buy your theory that the world changed with nine 11 really all that
much.
I got to disagree with that.
I think we've never been the same.
I think we may have had some trends that were leading to where we are now,
but they're the kind of things that wouldn't have happened without that.
It's almost like,
you know,
yeah,
we're on a precipice or something,
but somebody has to shove and nine 11 is like a Pearl Harbor.
When the explosion of the battleship Maine,
it's or,
or,
or the,
the,
you know,
the first world war starts with maybe the most significant terrorist attack and
human history.
One guy shoots a guy and his wife and the whole world explodes.
Well,
the world was poised to explode and he lit the powder keg.
But does the powder keg ever get lit if he doesn't do that?
So I mean,
that's what we're talking.
We were in an era where maybe there was a terrorist powder keg and a bunch of
things ready to happen,
but unless you have two buildings fall down,
or some guy said,
Dan,
more than two buildings fell down in New York.
Don't you know that if you,
unless you have a number of buildings fall down in New York on nine 11.
Does it ever have that push that sends you over the edge?
Yeah.
The,
uh,
the idea of a historical moment.
It's always been fascinating to me because when they happen you're like,
Whoa,
is this really happening?
Is this,
is that weird feeling?
[inaudible] 11.
And feel surreal when you watched lately surreal.
Every,
well,
I remember very clearly on nine 11,
I was hanging out with Joey Diaz,
Ralphie May,
Mike favor men and uh,
we were,
we were all like,
we were hanging out first.
Me and Joey were having a burrito whereas outside of Baja fresh on sunset and
we're looking up at the sky and we're like,
dude,
there's no planes.
Like there haven't been any plans.
Did you really?
Yeah,
there was no plans to notice that I,
that would never hit me.
I would never notice that.
Well,
I think I'd heard about it that they were going to cancel flights and then I
realized it once we were out there because it just sort of sunk in the whole
moment was from the moment the planes hit the towers to watching the replays on
TV.
It was,
it was almost like a bubble had popped,
like a door had opened,
like a new chapter.
It started.
That's what we're talking about here.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You know what's rare?
And we said this in the latest podcast,
so sorry to anybody who is already heard this,
but these events happen all the time,
but most of the time you don't realize it.
It's subtle.
It's,
you know,
we're living a day to day existence and historians 500 years from now,
we'll go.
They didn't even realize what an important moment of change,
but there are those moments that happen sometimes where the people who are
living through them,
there's so momentous that you can tell that you just go,
wow.
And yet we were like,
I mean,
I remember the whole day I'm getting like 200 phone calls from people going,
oh,
what does this mean?
I mean,
everybody knew something was going on.
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
those weird moments,
those weird breakthrough moments or things change completely.
The,
we,
we loved them and we're terrified of them.
But you know,
I mean,
they're,
they're really exciting sometimes,
but,
uh,
we're also absolutely terrified of a big event happening.
And that's one of the things they use to justify spying on people.
Like all this NSA thing,
like Bill Maher saw bill Maher justifying NSA spying.
It was really fascinating.
And his,
he doesn't,
it's not that he has a bad point either.
His point was there's something that we have now that didn't exist when they
were writing the constitution and its nuclear weapons.
That's a good point.
I mean if you really did find out that there was a possibility of a nuclear
attack on a certain area of the world and you could stop it because of these
strategies,
these,
these technological strategy.
But here's where I would go with that because I want,
this has always happened.
We just finished a show on the Spanish American war era and Teddy Roosevelt is
trying to tell people in the u s congress who keep bringing up the constitution
that that might have been fine in the age of sale,
but we live in the age of steam now and all of a sudden Europe isn't that far
away and these oceans aren't protecting us as much as they used to.
You know,
it's,
we've been dealing with that pretty much since men at one.
So I mean I think you can make that argument.
And we're in the age of drones now.
We didn't have any,
either they're timeless and their human rights and you're born with them.
Or as soon as things get dangerous enough they're gone.
I mean,
I think we have to sit down and have the conversation because I don't think the
guy,
and this is funny because you know,
you talk about the founding fathers,
like they're gods and then we realized that they have slaves and that they were
vulnerable levels.
And so fuck those slaves.
It's just,
it's one of those things where you can't,
you can't romanticize it too much.
But at the same time they were talking about these things as human rights,
not you get them now and we'll see what happens when they developed steam power.
You right.
So we have to decide what our commitment is to them.
If it's a real commitment than it doesn't matter what the next weapon system is
because it's more important to have the human rights than it is to be protected
from nuclear weapons.
If you want to be protected from nuclear weapons,
you might have to jettison some human rights.
Right.
But at least frame it that way.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a fascinating thing that every point in human history,
every single point,
if you could stop on that number,
that will have been the most advanced humans had ever been up until then.
You know,
and that's hard for us to wrap our heads around that the same sort of scenarios
keep playing themselves out over and over and over again.
And even though we're pretty convinced that,
you know,
we learned something from the,
the Greek and the,
the,
the Russian history and the,
uh,
the history of Rome,
we've learned something from all the lessons of how things went wrong.
What was good about thing was what was good about the government,
what was good about the philosophies that they had created and the ideas that
they shared.
But it's basically the same thing as it's going on now.
I'll tell you what,
we bring up a lot.
I hope I haven't overdone it and the shows,
but I'm fascinated by this idea that we're never going to go backwards.
Yes.
You know,
when you talk about,
you know,
this modern world and you look around and you think,
okay,
basically since the renaissance,
it's been all,
if this is the stock market,
we've been going up ever since the renaissance and the idea that everybody has
is that,
and we're never going to go backwards.
We're never going to go look at a thousand years from now and see people who
don't know about DNA sequencing anymore.
It's planet of the Apes,
right?
Where you've gone backwards and Oh,
the of liberty's partly
buried in the sand.
And I mean we,
we,
but every other culture,
but every other country in the [inaudible] civilization and history of the world
has thought that.
I mean,
you didn't think the Romans were thinking,
God,
it's great.
Now pity it can't last year.
But we learned from them.
We know,
maybe we,
and not just that,
maybe the whole globalization and the fact that everybody's connected,
we'll change that dynamic.
But I think if you're gonna,
if you're trying to learn from history,
one thing history shows is these stock market upticks in the civilization stock
market don't last.
So what does that mean?
Well,
we like to think we're more special than all the other animals first and
foremost.
So we would like to think that,
you know,
even me,
I'm guilty this guilty,
absolutely as charged.
We'd like to think that we are eventually going to cheese,
achieve the highest levels of understanding and that that's the trend that
things are going and eventually going to work everything out.
And we won't have war someday in the future.
And that somehow or another,
we are basically human beings are basically good.
And,
uh,
we're gonna work this out in the universe is going to reward that.
But I got one word,
one word that refutes that.
Dinosaurs.
Okay.
The whole world was fucking run by Conti,
heartless lizards,
cold blooded monsters without a fucking Spec of emotion that never wrote a
fucking thing down.
Didn't give a shit about culture,
would eat their babies,
would eat anything that stood still.
That's what dominated this earth for the longest time.
And if it wasn't for an asteroid impact,
very likely would still be a version of that animal still running shit.
I'll tell you what blew my mind.
I read this book by a guy named Nick Bostrom who's a physicist and whose,
whose expertise is the science of catastrophe,
right?
He studies catastrophic events and he's written whole books with,
with a lot of other physicists who do this about the various ways we could end.
And one of the ways involve something called the Fermi paradox,
but you may have heard about,
which is,
you know,
they do these mathematical studies and they figured out how many planets in the
universe should be like ours and should be able to support life.
And then they do the calculation down,
down,
down and try to figure out how many thousands or tens of thousands or millions
of planets should have human life or something intelligent.
And then they say,
so where are they?
So the Fermi paradox is the,
if the numbers add up the way they do,
where are they?
And guys like Bostrom if figured out that every intelligent civilization reaches
a point where it could very easily destroy itself or collapsed like a house of
cards or what.
And it's like this dangerous membrane and maybe he says it's after you'd involve
nuclear weapons.
And so the question is is most civilizations do not make it through this danger
zone from the time they develop nuclear weapons to the time they become like a
Gandhi civilization or whatever and most dies somewhere in that area that we're
now in right now.
And so the idea is that maybe this is where
we go back to dinosaurs.
Well,
it's an interesting paradox that the survival of the fittest mentality,
this,
this inner desire to conquer and survive and stay alive is also the exact same
thing that leads to innovation,
which is the exact same thing that leads to the highest levels of consciousness
and in technological innovation when they figured out how to bypass the human
body,
but yet they're still trapped.
And these trends of behavior that are based on just teeth and claws survival.
You know,
they're those,
those,
those instincts that drove us to get to the point where we're,
this evolved being,
you talk about a giant bunch of them in your podcast and some of them just as
recently as six,
700 years ago or reason than that.
Yeah.
The craziest thing ever is listening to,
you know,
you talk about,
um,
history that was only a few hundred years ago,
only a few,
you think 12,
13,
14,
15 generations.
That's,
that's nothing.
And they were living like insane people.
Well,
and the truth is the way that they were living was a lot more like they were
living in the time of ancient Egypt than we're living like any of them now.
And they're really living an unreal lifestyle in terms of what's normal for
human beings.
Whereas through most of human history,
they lived something much closer to the reality that the entire history of the
species understood.
Yeah.
No,
I,
I completely agree.
And you know,
we're talking about big great historical events.
The one,
the one that doesn't really get as much credit as I think it deserves is the
internet.
Oh yeah.
The Internet.
It didn't,
it didn't happen that quick.
It happened like a s it's a slowly hidden fines and got deepened.
Dora,
what do you think if you had to put a year or a year or two or three,
when do you think it hit critical mass and just,
yeah,
broke.
It seemed to me to be the early two thousands the internet became really
popular,
live without,
and everybody had to Wynnona writers.
The only person not on the Internet now.
Yeah,
it was,
it seemed like,
and that was the years where it started to escalate as far as like the
interesting articles that you could get,
the bandwidth situation had kinda gotten a lot better with people.
Every commercial had a web address at the bottom of it.
You could get a really quick Internet connection pretty much everywhere in the
early two thousands by the time that rolled around.
That made the experience so much more interesting.
I think maybe I'm not dating it,
that
I remember when the first web browser that people that average idiots could use
when the Netscape browser came on,
it was all of a sudden like,
oh,
I don't have to be a computer whiz to figure out how to click on this thing and
click on this thing and see something,
a read some news.
And I remember ladies,
gentlemen,
we're going to be able to talk about those of us as old as Joe Rogan and yours
truly going to be able to tell our children about the wild west of the Internet.
When you would just click around and look,
because there was some seriously weird stuff out there and you didn't,
there used to be the button is,
it's still there was says take a chance or,
but
now it does not take a chance and you're at best buy.
But then it was like taking a chance and it was,
oh my God,
what did I just land on?
Some serious could say no internet.
I remember when there was no internet.
That's like our walking up the hill both ways.
My children,
my children look at me and I talk about,
you know,
pre smart phones and they just rolled their eyes.
Oh Dad,
how old are you kids?
11 and eight.
What a fascinating life.
It's going to be for a child growing up in their life that they don't even have
it.
They sit there and just look down at things all the time.
Even when my brother was talking to me today about ads and he runs a business
and I said,
do you ever take out advertising?
He goes,
why?
Nobody ever looks up.
He goes,
you can get a billboard.
Nobody's going to see it.
They walk around looking down on it.
They're going to have neck problems when they get older.
Well,
they are having neck problems in Korea.
Was there a high incident of neck bulges,
bulging discs,
and then when people evolve in in a hundred years,
we're going to have like this curvature where we're like a microphone or one of
those heat lamps.
Bentos I don't think so.
I think the days of holding things in your hand are few and it's going to be the
glasses and it's going to be those and something new and I something in your
eyes.
Wiener thought he had trouble before.
Wait till the Google glass or if we need thought he was having fun before.
You know the actual videos now it's only in trouble when he's getting caught.
It seems like he's having a really grand time when no one's bothering him.
You know,
I say,
look,
the Guy Sends Dick Pics is obviously people that want to receive him.
He's played a little game.
Everyone's dancing.
Who Cares?
Well again,
you know he can't be mayor,
but I was just going to say white,
go into private prayer.
Charge money.
Having a web podcast,
you can,
but the type of person that wants to run days pick of the day brought to you by
wieners wound.
Your attempt to who would sponsor the sponsorship ideas become quite
interesting.
We had a podcast,
I think it would be quite popping [inaudible] superstore or you take all of his
freak instincts aside.
The guy's very charismatic.
If you ever heard [inaudible] huge,
like six foot five.
What are you doing?
This is the wiener chick.
Oh,
I don't want to see her.
Don't give her any tension.
The whole thing.
I thought I heard.
He's like six foot five.
He's like,
he's huge,
dude.
Somebody told me he's in an enormous human being.
I can't confirm that.
Maybe that's why he's got that giant hog.
Well,
that's why you just can't wait to,
somebody said to me,
would you be tweeting it out if it,
you know,
I mean,
no,
you wouldn't be,
but if your name was wiener and you had a giant hog and you were crazy,
you might,
yeah.
There's nothing wrong with it.
This is what I say.
I say,
yeah,
the guy's a fucking mess and I wouldn't want to be married to him,
and he know he can't be mayor.
But the fact that in the middle of
Yugoslavia thinking what u s cities would,
you know,
they'd be working it.
There's places where that was the fact that we're concentrating on that.
In the middle of this NSA thing,
in the middle of this Michael Hastings conspiracy theorists that say it.
That's why we're getting fed.
It's amazing.
Imagine we find out this chick's a CIA agent.
She was hired to lure Anthony Wiener because he's too cares what?
Remember the British government got brought down in the,
in a scandal with,
with KGB chicks.
Yeah.
So I mean it's happened.
Yeah,
it has happened.
Those Russian checks.
I'll get ya.
And this,
this,
what's really fascinating.
It was before this guy got busted.
He was a really charismatic guy.
He's a really good speaker and he was really dynamic and he made a lot of good
points.
And it's kind of fascinating that those like really charismatic guys,
they're also the ones who really love pussy.
Well,
you know,
but,
but listen,
I mean we want things to exist in like this really unrealistic way.
Those JFK,
dude,
those guys aren't wanting to be president.
They all were like crazy.
We're partners.
He had some girlfriends,
you know,
Gandhi had a gang of bitches just waiting for him at the House with incense or a
double load.
Let's ask the more interesting question.
If you are concerned as we often point out in our political podcast about the
low level of leadership,
I mean if you,
if countries rise or fall based on the sustained level of leadership and good,
well led countries do better.
I mean if companies well led do better than poor led companies,
what about countries?
And if the really good leaders come with these known flaws and we know that
there,
if you really want a good leader is going to come with all these personal
foibles.
And would you rather have the guy who's gifted at government with all his fault
or the mediocre guy,
but you know,
he doesn't ever do it.
There's no drugs in his background.
There's no sex,
no,
he's never done it.
He's been an accountant and clapped her racers,
but he's,
he's mediocre at leadership.
What do you take?
Well,
I'm certainly not delusional and I know that I forgot who I was and had all of
his phone.
I appears of a loaded question,
wasn't it?
No.
Clinton appears to me,
you know,
by,
by all accounts to be a very intelligent man.
And a very good leader,
but if you listen to some of the people that would talk about the atrocities
that were committed during his regimes,
the key is that he was involved.
There was a military actions that were very questionable.
They all have some pain,
man.
These,
this whole Democrat,
Republican Clintons,
none of these people are liberal.
None of these people.
I mean it's the,
it's a,
it's,
it's what it,
Noam Cha,
not Noam Chomsky.
What did that Gore Vidal said.
We have one party in this country with two wings and the wings are called
Democrats and repo.
It's,
I can't,
well,
he's had a great joke about it.
Which one wants it?
I remember he goes,
he goes,
this is politics in this country.
Goes,
I liked the puppet on her left.
Yes.
Well,
the pulpit on the right seems to me
George Carlin and some good ones too.
And you just go,
look,
if we could get over that,
we might actually make some progress.
But if you go the most depressing thing for me in the entire world.
But I also think it's one of the coolest things that happened on the Internet
are those comments sections underneath all the news stories where people can
sort of,
in one sense,
I think that's the greatest thing ever invented because the media hates that.
I mean to have it shorter,
but on the other hand,
when you read it,
it's like I could pretend that racism is almost a thing of the past and you go
on some of these sites and you read what some of these people,
right,
and you go,
oh my God,
I hope this isn't representative.
And then you read the,
the left and the right,
just eviscerating and I'll cut the throat of a liberal or Conservative need to
be exiled off the planet.
You're like,
oh,
we are totally,
this is really
representative of what's out there.
You know what I saw?
You want to,
you want to stop gun control or do you want,
you want to stop the gun issue,
kill everyone with a gun.
Seriously,
it did not us.
Actually.
Somebody actually wrote that.
They're not.
Please tell me there's 1% of the people who posted an inordinate amount,
all these new stories and that that's what that is.
As opposed to just new stories on everything to express yourself freely.
Like every anonymous habit.
Yes.
Except in the NSA,
what you're always going to have a giant percentage of the people that are like
really unbalanced spending a lot of time doing that.
Like one of the things I would really enjoy doing and whether it has anything to
do with me or not,
but when anytime I read someone criticizing someone,
I like to go and see like what other posts they make.
Like where,
where else do they make posts?
And it's almost always like you read someone's Twitter when they say something
mean he'd go to it and it's just all mean shit to random people all day.
They're just spewing out to celebrities to,
to,
uh,
you know,
entertainers to athletes,
to politicians to whatever.
They joke to.
Random cam girls,
random girls who have like websites.
I'm telling you,
man,
the,
I see some of these people,
it's just like you'd go to their website,
it's,
it's like you're watching madness.
You're watching,
well wait a minute.
That's their expression of who they are.
Think about that.
I mean there's mad crazy people out there who didn't have an internet to play
with 30 years ago and who do now.
Absolutely.
And also Manson and the old and the 60s would've had,
you know,
the,
the Internet to play with them.
Imagine how the recruitment would have gone for Manson with the Internet.
Yeah.
Well he probably would have been exposed quicker too.
You know,
they would have been like,
he's a hope.
So first of all,
he would have released all his songs on iTunes and he would have been a big star
and it never would have gone this way and he wouldn't have tried to kill that
beach boy,
Doris Day daughter Guy,
you know,
Terry Melcher and it never would have happened.
Maybe or it would have happened bigger.
Right?
Yeah.
The,
I think the,
the Internet is certainly probably encouraged a lot of people to be assholes,
exposed a lot of people for being assholes.
But what concerns me is that we have no precedent in this ability to communicate
with people without a physical reaction from them,
without being in front of them.
Like one of the reasons,
like we recognize humanity in each other.
If you say something mean to someone and you see them react to it,
you feel bad.
You know,
like there's like a,
there's like a give and take an energy like exchange between two people when
they're communicating with each other.
But the fact that someone with no previous interaction with you could just snipe
at you,
your song fucking sucks.
I hope you die in a fire.
Your whole band should get aids like you,
you read these things.
It's like no one's ever been able to do that before.
You've never been able to in a fee.
Like I can write you an email and in the exact same way they can contact you.
You're looking at something that they wrote on a screen.
So it can be someone who,
you know who,
who's a friend or it can be some fucking crazy,
but it gets to you the exact same way it gets to you as words.
And that's better about this than I am because I am really,
and this is like asking for,
it isn't,
but I'm a little too thin skinned for some of this stuff too because you know,
you're right,
you get this stuff and they send you these notes or or emails or reviews or
whatever.
Can they say stuff and you sit there and go,
okay,
this isn't constructive criticism and y w I don't want to whine about this.
You kind of look and go,
what motivated you to do that?
Cause,
but like you said,
I mean it's a cross section of human beings.
You don't know what mood they were in,
what they've been drinking or anything else.
But at the same time you do,
you kind of question,
you go,
is this what you do every day?
But it is,
you know,
it is
with some of this and with some,
they just all of a sudden decide that Dan Carlin needs a talking to and they get
online and they start fucking getting crazy and you know,
it's,
it's a weird way of communicating.
We're also talking to kids more,
you know,
awesome.
Talking to mental health people or we're talking to people that are in homes
that have that Internet that should not,
oh,
I don't know about that,
but one of the best,
how about that guy that got fired?
I remember that guy from,
he was in Houston and uh,
he was a reddit poster and actually got fired from his job when they found out
who he was on reddit because apparently he would post like dead bodies and crazy
shit.
Shit.
Like really,
really freaky shit.
And 10,000 lines mean things who say like really vicious mean Shit.
And it turned out he was like a guy with like a family wife and kids.
You were talking about this internet and how it's changing things and really I
always try to point out how early we are in this whole thing development.
Think about though,
how it does empower people like that,
who ever,
I mean it's,
I mean we always talk about how great it is that we can do podcasts and that we
can talk to a huge audience through a microphone out of,
out of a room or whatever.
But it does the same thing for everyone there.
And it's interesting when you think about people who,
I mean they used to talk about the voiceless.
You'll read these histories about these people locked up in these dark buildings
and never got it there.
The voiceless,
not anymore.
There's no voiceless.
It's not like the old days where someone could just,
you know,
be a famous person like Elvis or something like that and no one ever can say
anything about him.
Like,
you know,
Elvis came over to my hotel room,
we eight 15 pills and shit in my mouth.
And you know these days,
like if something like that happens,
like someone's going to take pictures,
they're going to put it up on Tmz Bank back in the day,
you know the,
there was,
there was people that had no voice,
they couldn't talk about anything.
They couldn't say this movie is pandering,
it's stupid.
It's treating you like you're an idiot.
They couldn't say like my new show,
like a lot of the criticisms I've read about my new show I agree with and I
think they're really valid and I think that people having the ability to do that
is important.
I don't like the fast editing.
I don't like some of the cheesy music.
I don't like the suspense,
the thrill.
That's the way they think.
They have to make TV shows though.
But as the show gets more and more popular,
hopefully we can show that that's not the case.
But like it's like this constant battle of compromise.
But what's important to me is that people were looking at it sort of a lot of
ways.
The same way I'm looking at it.
The things that they don't like about it.
I don't like about it.
So it's validating in a way.
Even though they're saying I suck.
It's like,
I know it kind of sucks in this way and I think there's a lot of great stuff
about it,
but we can fix the suck part.
The stuck part is just like everyone assumes that you have to do it this certain
way because they've done it that way forever and they're scared.
But when you look at these comments and you read things online,
everyone bad,
crazy,
but also good and poignant in,
in,
in people who have good points of view,
they'll point stuff out and you go,
this is undeniable.
Yes,
the,
you know,
this is cheesy.
Yes.
This is a dumb way to do that.
This is demeaning to people's intelligence.
These,
right.
I'll give you the example though of what I mean and I'm thinking about people in
the Pre-internet age that were both geniuses and dangerous as all get out and
were dangerous before the end of the perfect example and only you punk rockers
out there will know who I'm talking about here,
but Darby crash from the germs.
Who was from he,
how dare you fuck knows what you're to be crashed.
And Darby crash was a genius,
a Weirdo genius.
And I remember he went on Rodney Bingenheimer show here in town in like 1979 and
started giving out the satellite codes so you could make free telephone calls
and he's on the radio announcing,
okay,
Naafi dial this number.
And so you could call it Pakistan and you won't have to pay a dime and hitting
it then this number and you dial this first and make sure you download one.
I mean,
imagine him on the Internet and every week it's like,
okay,
subversive podcast one on one.
I mean,
he'd be gone in like five minutes,
but you think about what those guys could achieve without an internet.
Now you've given a Darby crash of the germs and internet and it's crazy thing.
I mean we're,
we're calling the internet a thing like as if it's a,
you know,
but what it did was it was a next,
if you look at it like really cleanly,
it's instead of like labeling the internet,
it's almost just like the next level of technology.
It's like,
it's just the ability to exchange information and then from there it's all that
information just taking off and growing.
Don't want you to think they're going to do that Internet though.
And,
okay.
And every time I say anything like this,
the real technophobes junk people,
actually,
no,
actually no,
you're talking about exactly.
But I mean the rumor has always been that they're going to create a commercially
oriented Internet and the one where ESPN can deliver their content,
everything and it'd be super rapid and no spam and no ads.
And then they'll have the other one.
We're all the spam and all the ads and it goes really slow and everything.
And that's where the Dan Carlin podcast will be.
And it'll take 17 days to download my lady with all the spam and stuff that
comes with it.
How could he make it slower than it is now?
They won't.
They'll speed up the other one and just looking at one to degrade.
That's okay.
I would way rather have what we have right now uncensored than anything that's
fast and I think everybody in fast and stupid and they get it and you go,
hey,
check this out.
This is the internet,
but you would still want to be able to do what you're doing
now is my point.
You wouldn't want to switch over and become censored so you can move faster.
I don't think that's,
I think the other one we just slowed down.
It was slowly but surely overwhelmed with junk and spam violates the laws of
technological progression.
I think the fact that you even need a technophobe to tell me that,
you could tell me that it's the,
I don't see how there could ever be any rational reason for a slowing in speeds
of Internet.
This the speeds.
It's a rhetorical mine.
If you're the government,
you're tired of these idiots on these pod kit on that,
but everything wouldn't you want to share?
Well,
but listen,
I know that the old TV networks and stuff,
they're not happy with the fact they've lost the monopoly over,
you know,
being the middle man for content.
If they've,
if you told them,
listen,
I have a plan that could put you back in the driver's seat.
You don't think they'd say,
oh I have a slot open up at 2:00 PM let's have a meeting.
I'd like to hear what you have to say.
No for a bunch of reasons.
Cause I would like to think that individually there realized that we'd be a
terrible thing for the human race.
But also as you've met all those guys and you know that that's how they think
about us enough to them individually to be caught up in something so dangerous.
Like when you start talking about something like a conspiracy that would involve
who knows how many thousands of people to slow down the Internet.
You know,
I mean it would be an insanely transparent venture.
No way you could hire me.
Pretend I'm coming in the meeting and I say in 1990 the average golden girls
episode that nobody cared about it all had 43 million people watching it.
Yeah,
you've got to blame that on direct TV as much as you have to blame it on
anything else or cable or a k instant on demand television programming,
you know without that.
What about Netflix?
You can get any fucking show you want anytime you want.
With the kind of like speed that we have now.
I mean I don't have the fastest Internet at home,
but I stream from Netflix in HD like it's nothing.
It's super easy,
so essentially I don't need a network anymore.
They're just as much to blame for this whole thing as the Internet.
It's certainly a lot more fragmentation.
There's no blame.
Well there is.
It is.
It's a progression.
You offer a shit product,
you stuffed fucking commercials inside that shit product and you wonder why
people are looking elsewhere when all of a sudden they have.
I agree with that that way.
Of course,
thinking about the best example,
I'm not talking about blame,
I'm talking about somebody saying,
listen,
I know you think the genie's out of the bottle,
but with my new plan,
I can put the genie back in the bottle so that,
I don't want to say any names.
Major media company number one,
two,
three,
and four or five.
You guys are,
I mean,
look,
if you're talking about movies and stuff like that,
are entertainment companies,
it's already just like three or four companies now.
I mean,
it's not the Joe Rogan or the Dan Carlin show,
but if you're talking about major media companies out there,
there used to be a ton,
and we're down to like three or four.
Isn't that fascinating?
Because it's sort of like banks as well,
how the eating each other up,
but it's almost like a survival mechanism.
You realize they had almost recognize that they were too big,
and then as the landscape change,
they were forced to coalesce.
It's really kind of fascinating as a male dog,
but if you're a blockbuster movie maker and you're going to $200 million,
you can't scrape that.
Uh,
together very easily and not only that,
you have to make sure that all your fucking t's are crossed and all your i's are
dotted and everything is like really clean and appealing.
Like that's why I'm moving it like Avatar.
I've loved Avatar.
I thought it was a really fun movie but it's a perfect blockbuster moneymaker
movie cause there's no sex.
The violence is like most of his life.
Either bad guys get jacked or you know these alien things which you don't even
really identify with.
The story is like Pocahontas,
it's a million other stories is dances with wolves.
It's a million other stories that had been done a thousand times before,
but it's done perfect.
That's a fucking $250 million movie.
That's a movie that they can,
but he's got to get a James Cameron type motherfucker that's knows how to do
those things perfect and can pull pulling those off.
But yeah,
in this day and age,
those are dying off slowly but surely it's harder and harder to make one of
those motherfuckers.
You don't know if you have an Avatar or an Ishtar until it comes out.
People don't even remember that.
Look,
that's a hell of a risk.
And Colin and I,
we're old folks that fucked.
Do you remember that?
Oh yeah,
they used to be,
but if every single [inaudible] world waterworld is another wire on the waves.
But there was one other one too.
What was the other one?
There was one other gigantic movie that was actually previous to that.
There was a,
God,
it wasn't a warrant.
Beatty movie.
Uh,
shreds was pretty,
I mean red's is pretty bad,
but there was another one that they talked about as being as much of a colossal
failure as a,
as Ishtar.
It was one of those like movie Robert Redford or something.
Some shit I would never watch.
You know,
when he falls in love with the girl who gets cancer or something,
I don't remember.
I don't remember those movies,
those,
those types of movies like this where the music would play.
Robert Redford look at these girls and it's like steely glance.
I know they're good,
but I'm not watching that shit.
My Dad,
my dad,
my dad made movies and he made movies that costs like $200,000 to make.
He spent like a million dollars on promotion.
He released them in like a physician theaters all at once and by the time you
realized that no one should have gone to that movie,
he made all his money back and then sold it overseas.
So that was the,
what was the move?
That and that and that was the playbook was shark Nino was that they make that
for Scifi or they made it specifically.
Yeah,
it's a brilliant move,
man.
Just go over the top,
make something completely retarded.
Did you see Insr and flying through the air inside the shark's mouth,
the sharks flying through the air.
I had jumps up with a chainsaw.
It goes inside the shark and cuts his way out the chain.
It's on my to do,
they're already making a sequel and yards.
Funny Shit.
And Ian's the only one that's going to be back in it and they know they're on a
Terry today.
She should get back.
She's crazy.
Get back in there.
Have your agent could kiss their ass,
end up sending a gift basket shark ate,
or as the,
the idea of,
uh,
making your own like really terrible movies on purpose.
It's great idea.
Let's do it.
I think,
I absolutely think,
especially in this day and age with all the weed,
but everybody having access to weed those movies became infinitely more popular.
Like Sharknado sober is not the best movie to watch,
but if you're high as fuck when you have two or more friends over,
you're going to have a great time.
That's a party.
I'm,
I'm advocating marijuana and shark NATO together.
People like,
what are you doing?
Are you advocating marijuana use Donald?
Only that I'm advocating marijuana use wild watching shark Nino.
I think that's an important statement.
Don't be scared.
Pitches
those tell terrible television shows.
They're fun.
There's a reason when they make them up bad on purpose.
But then there's like subtle ones.
Like I've argued with people about,
um,
Werner Herzog's a grizzly man.
Dunkin thinks that Werner absolutely knew that he was making a comedy as he was
making it and just used his narration.
And you know,
tried to like make it dramatic and legitimate,
but new while he was doing it that he was making a comedy.
There's a part of me that wonders if Jack Webb didn't know those dragnets that
he was making sure that those were fucking,
there's still,
there's still hilarious,
the kind of the statements that he would say and the way he talked and just go
pull some of those up because Larry Dragnet
68 grizzly man though to like normal people that aren't comics and you don't
give them any kind of precursor laugh.
They know they don't come back thinking like,
oh my God,
that guy was gay.
That's so fake.
They like,
cause I know a few people that said it well when I said that,
they're always like,
oh yeah,
I guess you're right.
Yeah,
he was kind of,
come on,
man.
Everybody watched that.
You knew he was good.
I think we just hang out with people that,
that are in the entertainment industry more so that we're all kind of thinking
shit like this.
No,
maybe,
I don't know.
Maybe,
but I,
I feel like when I watched grizzly man,
I mean the guy's holding a camera and he's walking around and talking to the
camera and one of the things he's saying is,
I wish I was gay because if I was gay,
I could just go to a truck stop.
I could just hook up with a guy,
but I'm not gay.
So what do I do?
And me personally,
I've always felt like anybody who's walking in the woods talking to a camera
saying,
I'm not gay,
it's 99% gay.
There's psychological formula you can follow.
But he just not something that a heterosexual person says,
unless you get called gay a lot in your whole life.
And he's by himself in the woods,
man by himself in the woods,
walk with a camera talking about why can't meet a woman and the motherfuckers
sleeping.
Flophouse exactly.
Sleeping into cloth,
house following monsters.
You know,
we just found out how you got that mixed breed with the Sasquatch and the,
you know,
how did you get the mixed breed?
Well,
we finally find the guy in the forest who couldn't meet a girl and then we'll
fuck to bear just some female Sasquatch.
It was basically suicide by bears,
what it was.
But you know,
I'll just,
we're getting off the point here,
the talk much history,
but we are sort of,
cause we're kind of setting it up.
Okay.
Even though this is like,
look,
I love talking to you about anything,
but we,
we got to talk about some history where people are going to be mad at us.
That's right.
Yeah.
But I think that in a sense we're kind of setting it up because with all this,
uh,
this madness,
whether it's Anthony Wiener or whether it's,
uh,
the NSA spying on us and justifying it.
W W all this madness,
it's the human animal is only really been aware of how crazy we are for the last
like few hundred years.
We've only been like paying attention and writing things down for the last few
thousand years.
And over the last few hundred years we like slowly but surely been like,
oh my God.
Like we're fucking crazy.
But I think today is a really unique time to,
for all the reasons why we were talking about before,
especially with the Internet and having this access to information.
Having things like your podcast today is like the most unique time ever to like
look at all this information about the past and sort of sum it up in this old
people are just nuts.
Like there's never been a point in time ever in human history where there was
peace on the whole earth for like a week or a month or a year.
Even though we'd like to think of ourselves as being inherently good and noble
and there's a few bad apples out there.
There's never been a time ever where people were nice to each other,
just universally like a PR.
Like here,
if it was just us,
I always use this example,
but it was just the four of us and we had a,
we had our own civilization and we lived on an island or we lived somewhere
where there was no fighting over resources.
I'm pretty sure we'd get along great,
you know?
I mean,
we're special force him though.
Really,
you might try to fuck Brian after a while.
I've seen that you mean you mean something might happen sexually but most likely
not and most likely we would all be very friendly and coexist for a long time on
that island with no issues.
Okay.
But why is that not the case when it comes to 4 million people are 4 billion
people or 4 trillion,
whatever the,
the the than the number of eventually becomes we s we can ever hold large groups
together without some really senseless shit happening and some regrettable stuff
happening.
And when you,
when you look at history,
when you talk about like the Roman Empire or you talk about Martin Luther and
when you talk about these people that existed just a few hundred years ago,
just not that long ago,
but they're living like they're in a mad world that's in a movie,
that thing I didn't hide.
First of all,
I knew nothing about Lutherism.
I didn't,
I never had heard of,
I mean I knew what it was.
I saw it on churches,
but I have no idea what the philosophy was and that it's based on Martin Luther
is based on this guy with the balls to actually like post notes complaining
about the Church and print them at that time where they weren't that cool about
killing people,
killing people who are doing that cool about no complaint department.
But what is the name of that podcast?
Uh,
God,
you can't do that to me.
Uh,
that one is called,
I'll find it on my head and look at a problem.
The profits and profits of doom never go backwards.
I never looked back.
Listen,
I understand.
Totally.
And for a guy who works as much as you do,
people might think that that's an excuse.
But I know about the human memory.
Well,
no,
listen,
when we would,
Brian and I do with this podcast,
we show up five minutes before we smoke a joint.
We talked a little shit and then we were role.
What you do is it should even be called a podcast.
It's a completely different experience.
People think I wait until the law cause it like writing,
come on,
good old.
They think I'm just sitting around and then all of a sudden let me explain it to
me.
Let me make him wait another week.
Let me explain to me though,
if you're a podcast fan and you like if you enjoy this podcast,
first of all,
thank you.
We enjoy you too.
Um,
but second of all like what he does is not a podcast.
It's like an audio presentation and they're a long well the his stomach.
Yes.
What if one of them,
the most recent one I'm into,
let me,
I'll pull up the name of it because you started off by talking about,
this isn't really a podcast,
an audio book.
This is essentially an audio book.
Do you know which one that was?
I'll tell you the last five probably.
It is.
No,
it's not wrath of the con man.
I played that so much.
You like Mars angels.
Of course.
I just hit you with a nerve cause you're a Mongol file too.
I've got a problem.
I've got a real problem with,
they've been in a motorcycle gang.
I listened to your Mongo podcast at least four or five times all the way over.
The Joe Rogan stopped telling Joe Rogan to talk about your mom podcasts on it.
I talked to this poor comedic woman about it and you said something and there
was,
we went back to her,
there's this long dead silence where she tried to absorb what you just told her.
Who was that?
Who Do you think that would have been female comedian?
She said,
I've got a show on costumer.
Yeah.
That's most likely to buy it.
And there's this long pause.
Like what do I say after that?
Yeah.
I went,
I hit Amy Schumer with some fucking crazy.
She's awesome.
Well,
you know,
we would though one of the images that you painted,
that's to me what,
like whenever,
when people talk about,
um,
the Mongols and I've had conversations with people where it's been brought up
about the Ganga is Khan Dna thing that Dan Gingiss cons Dnas and some insane
percentage of maybe that's been challenged.
Well and not his specifically,
but his,
his family,
his sons had admitted mean just more and more and more wives.
And they had a lot of wives anyway.
And you know,
uh,
it's possible in certain areas like they can go into places like Afghanistan and
there were a whole populations there where there's just a huge amount of people
you can trace to his family.
They would,
they would leave these garrisons to keep these places pacified.
And it's like,
what I always tell those people about the Mongols are so tolerant and they had
these and any religion and they whole things.
I said,
yeah,
they were tolerant if you gave in and giving in kind of meant,
okay,
you have a beautiful daughter,
she's mine now.
Well,
they're tolerant.
I mean,
Hitler was tolerant if you gave in.
Yeah.
What they didn't enforce is an ideology because they didn't give a fuck.
Romans didn't either,
hey,
pay your taxes.
I don't care what weird religion you're a part of it,
you know?
And if you don't worship the emperor,
you're in big trouble idea that that is what's important.
Not the fact that they were the most murderous the world
has ever known.
When you said,
and I,
I couldn't believe this,
I had a pause my fucking computer and I had to go online and find verification
when you were saying that they might have killed between 50 and 80 [inaudible]
during the period of Gingiss cons,
life by fucking horseback.
You're not his life,
but he and his,
his up to his grandchildren,
grandchildren.
Oh,
okay.
I want to tell the audience,
I get this phone call one night and it's,
I can hear the wind through his ears and it's Joe Rogan go.
Did you just use them?
Bill Cosby skid in the middle of talking about Genghis Khan?
No,
not a skit.
No.
You had a correct,
brilliant analogy.
I go,
how awesome.
I you,
you,
he talked about bill Cosby raising his children and how bill Cosby grew up poor
in Philadelphia,
but it's children grew up the,
the children,
one of the most loved man ever rich,
rich beyond recognition.
I mean real bill Cosby's got a fucking billion dollars and then you compared
that to get his cars.
Kids were kingus,
Khan grew up,
they were
beautiful depictions of people wearing mouse skin clothes,
like there were so poor,
they had field mice that they would skin and turn them into clothes.
So you definitely this crazy person coming at you with
hail in the snow to school both ways.
I mean it was that,
but you know,
comparing that to bill Cosby was brilliant.
It was so fun.
I just,
when I talk about,
uh,
Theodore Roosevelt and how the,
every little American kids favorite president is Theodore Roosevelt because
Theodore Roosevelt is like a kid.
And one guy said when he was president said,
you must always remember the president is about six.
And so I compared him,
you know,
as always wanting to go on these adventures as being like,
and,
and by the standards of our time now,
he was a racist.
He was at,
when they say about six,
they would say that about him.
He was about six [inaudible] well but,
but,
but so I didn't want to say he was racist because by the time he was considered
progressive on race,
but by today's standards he make Archie bunker looked like a liberal.
So I always said he's like,
he's like a heavily armed imperialistic racist version of Peter Pan and Larry
are,
you have this image of Teddy Roosevelt with the little glasses and the buck
teeth,
the mustache and bullying,
bullying Peter Pan Leading you off to war on a great adventure in Spain.
Yeah.
He would like get in fist fights and shit.
Right?
Oh,
for the fun of it.
He used to,
he used to,
he used to buy,
I mean the guy was blind in one eye later in his life because he would box in
the White House because that's to me a manly thing to do to block and went and
lived on a dude ranch because he thought that,
you know,
you need to hang out with cowboys and mountain men and stuff.
You know,
he had one of the first depictions of Sasquatch in one of his books.
You know that one of his books,
someone got killed by a wild man,
I'm sure you would like to hunt Sasquatches head on the wall.
And that's like one of the,
when the,
the Sasquatch nutters,
when they use a information,
when they start talking to me about stories that people have told,
that's one of them.
They tell with great
glee,
the Teddy Roosevelt Sasquatch story.
And you know,
Teddy Roosevelt read about Sasquatch and one of his dad's body is telling you,
you'll see one of his camps,
it's hunting camps.
One of the men that was with him was killed by wild man.
Well,
I'm sure a story from the 1940s holds up liking
whatever it was.
I'm sure it holds up like a month while I was high off,
holds up like a motherfucker in 2013 like you couldn't tell me a Sasquatch story
from a month ago and I believe you got it right.
You tell me about a guy who got killed by a wild monkey man and the early 19th
century or 20th century.
The,
um,
the story that we were talking about before the podcast,
I said,
you gotta stop,
you gotta stop.
Gotta stop.
It was about the Michael Crighton movie based on a real life encounter with
humans in the Anatol.
A buddy of mine gave me that book,
it's called eaters of the dead a long time ago.
And what the author Michael Crighton didn't he right.
Jurrasic park and stuff.
So he had found,
and it's something that historians know about,
uh,
a manuscript written by a Muslim guy and like the 10th century,
the Khalif sends this guy out to explore lands in a specific direction and he
writes about all the people that he meets.
So,
you know,
he goes a little north,
he writes about the people in the southern Russia.
It keeps going.
He keeps going.
Eventually he gets,
you know,
at one point he writes about whales,
but he doesn't know what a whale is.
So he's in this book trying to describe a whale and Crighton takes this guy's
original manuscript and sort of adds to it and writes a little connecting
pieces.
But at one point in the story,
this guy who will get his head cut off by the Khalif if he lies.
So the,
the general understanding is that there wasn't a lot of exaggeration going on
here because this guy was kind of tell the truth or I'll kill you.
He makes it to Sweden during the Viking era and gives us really the only good
written description of like the Swedish vikings known as the Reus and,
and I don't know where Crighton begins in the story leaves off.
So don't quote me on this,
but this Swedes,
or having some kind of war that Michael Crighton has it interpreted that it's
like this Swedish vikings against the last tribe of neanderthals pushed up
against the frozen north.
You know,
people have been pushing them out of the good areas forever.
And the last bastion is up here in the frozen north and they'll,
Swedish vikings are constantly at war with them.
And that's what the 13th warrior movies about and all that.
But the actual text is fascinating to read and it's a true historical text.
I mean,
the guy's name is like even five lean or something.
My Muslim pronunciations are always off,
but,
but it's fascinating stuff.
And,
and found this and just said this is better than anything anybody could write.
I mean it's wonderful stuff,
but I think they,
they butchered it for the movie,
right?
Oh yeah,
no,
they know.
Even the book is Crighton you know,
plays around the margins.
But yeah,
I didn't even see the movie once.
I,
Antonio Banderas and I knew tell you this is a bad motherfucker for a long
period,
but not with a sword and armor and Melanie Griffin cries and your shoulder for
the thousandth time.
You're like,
okay,
I can't make the Zombie plays a good cat.
He's like a piece of bad motherfucker.
Another spy kids movie.
The um,
the,
the movie was like,
they were wearing outfits and then work like cannibals.
They fucked the whole thing up because the movie looked like they were monsters.
It looked like when you watched it,
like the previews and they showed you the clips,
it looked like these guys were going up against these cannibal monsters that
would eat people.
And that's what you thought about even saying,
you know,
he would write in the Italian,
so the regular thing would be all print,
the original report,
and then then you could see the word workrite and would say,
what the heck is he talking about?
Here are these neanderthals.
And that's,
that's kind of how they came about.
And you kind of,
if you're going to make a movie,
like they did a movie that I hated on the Greek and Persian wars,
that one 300 with the Spartans,
you know,
hated 300 by him over man thing.
I had a guy,
another history guy who was so mad at all the inaccuracies of the Persians,
right?
Making them look like the monsters.
And I said,
but you know what I mean?
I can see how the the director,
if you were trying to make it look as weird to you,
the viewer as it must have looked to the Greeks at the time,
that then you would have to exaggerate because if you showed the Persians as
they really are to our,
you're going,
okay,
what's the big deal?
They look right,
but if you want to the Greeks,
these were really exotic freaky thing.
So if you want to make it look as freaky to you,
the viewing audience as it looked to the Spartans,
you would have to make it more monsters and more wicked and wild.
And so that's,
I tried to explain it to my buddy.
For us,
it was,
to me,
the reason I hated is because the story itself is so mind blowing.
Don't screw it up with all that other stuff.
But yeah.
But,
but that's a really interesting perspective that I hadn't considered.
If you want to make it as weird to you as it was to them,
you have to make it.
Yeah.
Well,
when the,
yeah,
I guess if you have very limited access to the reality of the world as far as
information goes,
and you see these guys coming over in elephants with,
you would really think that there's,
oh,
and then,
and they thought all that stuff from Persia was exotic and decadent.
Weird.
And you know,
it's fucking beautiful movie.
I love that movie.
It was so much fun visual comic book,
right?
Yes.
Exactly.
See that's what I've liked.
Those movies,
like people will like poke holes in Avatar.
I think Avatar is also a visual comic book.
But there's a difference.
And I have this,
I don't have any problem with a story like that.
Right.
Cause like when Oliver Stone doesn't move you like the doors or the j I want to
just,
I don't know.
I can't say I want to kill all it.
There's no,
but I mean it makes you angry cause you just,
or like when he did Alexander the Great,
oh my God.
And then you find out that Martin Scorsese had wanted to do Alexander the Great
and then stopped because Oliver Stone was doing and you go,
oh my God.
And you know why?
Because,
because Alexander,
his whole life is like a mafia crime family.
And you think what better director than Martin Scorsese and you put Joe Pesci in
it and you know,
fantastic.
And no,
he has to stop because you know,
what does this brand the equal to 300 that's coming out?
Oh it is?
Yeah.
When is it coming out?
I think next year.
Oh,
I'm so happy now.
I love the idea of these times,
man.
And obviously this is a lot of fuckery fun and you know,
fantasy and monsters.
They are wild.
There was wild.
I love that era too.
It's my favorite is just the idea of these movies is so fun.
We're way past the time on the podcast and,
and unfortunately I'm going to do,
I think that me telling you all here for the first time,
I think we're going to do another big modern series,
but then I'm going back to the ancient world.
It's my first law than we'd been away from there for mom to me Mongols or later
history.
I mean,
I love that BC stuff.
Do you really?
I love it.
Wow.
It's another world.
The Martin Luther's story,
which we sort of touched upon.
Um,
but we,
we didn't really go any further.
We've got sort of sidetracked.
What's Waco in Germany?
That's the math.
That's what Waco could have been had it been a huge,
bigger story.
But what's fascinating about it to me was that Martin Luther has these ideas.
He's this legitimate guy.
And he also takes the Bible and translates it so people can read it.
He takes the Bible and translates it phonetically for the longest time,
and I wasn't aware of this,
people couldn't read the Bible.
They had to go to church and the priest had to tell them what was in the Bible.
People got mad at me too when I said it.
A couple of,
you know,
you had a lot of biblical scholars out there and they gave me the whole thing
about what you had this the vulgate Bible and level.
But basically though it's a true statement,
which is that most people,
especially in places like Germany,
are not reading Latin during this time period because they're not,
they're not reading anything basically.
And of course,
Latin itself is just there that's translated.
It's not even alive language at that time.
You know,
you'd say it's a dead language.
Now.
There weren't a lot of people outside the church walking around speaking Latin
on the streets and it's translated another dead language and ancient Hebrew.
So there's ancient Greek,
they weren't even Hebrew to Greek,
Greek to Latin,
and not always gap.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
I'm not going there with you.
There's people that study this stuff all day.
The idea is first,
first and foremost,
that Martin Luther was one of the very first people to distribute this
information,
dangerous information and make it so that people would know what's actually in
the Bible and it was a big controversy about whether the people could handle it
without a middle man to interpret it for them.
Because think about this is this is hard for modern people because even when you
truly believe the Bible is the word of God,
you're still living in this modern civilization where you no doubt is out there
and you know it.
It still influences you even on a subconscious level.
Whereas these people,
if you really believe 100% know if Sandra and everybody around you did too.
You lived in a culture where everybody believes that this is exact the exact
word of God,
and now these scholars whom you trust are telling you to interpret it for
yourself.
That idiot who wrote the negative reviews on the Internet from the insane asylum
is told,
hey,
you too can interpret this for yourself.
And then what's going to,
and the Catholic church was in a moment of,
we have to say real sanity here going that could be a little dangerous,
don't you think?
Well they knew it was a quantum leap.
It was a historical moment.
You know,
it was almost like a,
not a catastrophe,
like a nine 11 but a historical moment of that significance for all of a sudden
it's hard for us to believe and understand exactly.
But people having the opportunity to read the Bible was as huge burst of change
that's spread through these communities.
When you think that you've been lied to,
which all of a sudden a bunch of people are like,
wait a minute,
why didn't they tell me?
No,
you're keeping the,
what do we compare it to?
In that episode we said if aliens came to us and they had the real word of God
and they said,
we have the real word of God and you're like,
oh my Lord.
Oh good.
Fantastic.
And they said,
but you can't read it cause it's an alien will tell you what it says.
I mean,
that's kind of one of the things I secretly love about your podcast.
You,
you'll bring up that alien scenario.
Why is it so great?
The alien and everybody says it's a drinking game.
Wednesday,
once Dan mentions aliens,
I know you brought,
you brought that up.
Now I'm playing with and you know what I was supposed to bring with me today,
some ointment with a fly in it because apparently the last time I was here,
I used the term fly in the ointment about 700 times.
And I go back to home and my buddy goes,
you never use,
I've never heard you use that phrase ever.
And I go and he said,
look at,
look at Rogan's discussion board.
Fly in the ointment flight.
What's it?
What the fly in the ointment.
The fly in the ointment.
You know?
And I thought,
that's gonna be my catch phrase now I'm just going to adopt it.
Embrace it.
You know,
you haven't said it once.
Have I have,
I Brian,
you know,
fly in the ointment this time.
Get to know who you got on the show.
That's hilarious.
That that's what they got out of that discussion.
Well,
I know there deep,
you know,
um,
the,
the Martin Luther thing,
what's fascinating to me is Martin Luther had some ideas,
but then these really radical Pete bill took his ideas and when way further they
went full on,
no one has private property,
you know,
like some sort of communism,
socialism agenda and I'm going to fuck all the women like they went.
So we did.
That is what happens whenever.
Okay.
It's a easy guy.
Gets a control.
A plus B equals I'm the Messiah and I can have all your wives.
I mean,
it just,
it's almost an algebraic expression.
I know you're all starving to death and I have plenty of food,
but seriously,
I'm supposed to be that way.
Well,
you know what's really funny is if you look at history,
that's that exact thing has happened.
Oh yeah.
I know.
And what I love about it is it's always we have to get back to the way it really
was with Jesus.
Was Jesus doing that or I don't remember Jesus saying,
and all your wives are mine.
They throw that in.
It's just like Jesus and all your wives are mind.
It always happens like the Waco guys.
Yeah,
but,
but it's happened like 500 yeah.
The Way Jeffrey's guy,
they all do it and there was a bunch of the,
the the,
I don't go here.
The one thing I mentioned something,
I'm going to get 10,000 people even before this period in Hungary,
there was a bunch of these free love movements and they based it all on the,
you know,
all this stuff does the guy in Siberia that says he's Jesus as he bang
everybody.
I don't know the guy in Siberia,
you don't know this guy.
Oh my God.
Vice did an incredible documentary on him.
He's got a village up there.
I mean have a large village where there's many,
many,
many people,
hundreds and hundreds of people.
I don't know how many,
it might be more than a thousand that in his community and the all of these
homes set up and they all show up in these meetings and churches and this guy
like lives on a hill.
He's just like,
Jeez,
Jesus,
that Jesus from Siberia and he comes down,
he blesses them,
he goes back up to his house and they all like sing songs and eat dinner
together and grow food.
No,
I believe truly believe that this predates Jesus.
That this is a human thing.
That there are either people are born with this genetic makeup or somebody
figured out a really great scam a long time ago that said,
you know,
I could just be either God or the Prophet of God and this would really work out
well for me.
What am I going to do for a living?
Ah,
it all looks terrible in hardware.
I could be a profit.
And like I said,
I think you could go long before Christianity and see these people running
around saying,
uh,
I'm not a witch doctor.
I'm the son of God.
Then it goes right back to,
to bring it up again,
the Alpha male primate instincts that have sort of flavored the,
the very progress,
the,
the need to conquer,
sort of flavored,
the very progress.
It all goes back to the same thing.
It's like one crazy thing that wants to run the whole Bot group of other people.
It's always the same.
It's like when you look at how freaky things get when people start questioning,
I mean like,
like the whole story of his real name is Amenhotep the fourth,
but [inaudible] is the way he's known in history though.
The supposedly the first monotheist a an Egyptian Pharaoh that decided that
there's only one God in an era where Egypt had an extremely powerful priestly
class and for ronic times who ran everything,
they were like the civil servants,
the bureaucracy,
the whole thing to read.
People who could read and he comes in there as the Pharaoh,
right?
A living God and says,
guess what?
This whole religion that we,
we've,
we've bazillions of years.
There's only one God.
I've changed it and it's the sun and this thing that happened.
They think he may have been assassinated after he dies,
the priests get back into power and cross off all of the pictures of him and the
hieroglyphics with his name and his face is scratched out a lot of them.
And,
and,
and that's the kind of revolution that's bigger than any of the kind that Luther
did.
Because you're not just saying the government's wrong,
or the societies or you're saying reality as you have known it is a lie and
we're going to change it.
And we in the modern world have never lived through anything like that.
I mean,
that,
that is a questioning of,
I mean,
we have things that you could say is a little bit like that,
but because we don't believe in a single truth as a society.
Yeah.
So you can't have somebody say that single truth that every one of you have
taken for granted is wrong.
I mean,
that's,
that's a wicked hundred and 80 degree,
you know,
shift in perceptions and you have to know something's gonna go wrong.
And that is that.
It's also really important that everybody doesn't agree on things.
That's a very,
very modern concept.
The only way infrastructure is going to get laid out and fucking pipes for facet
and that connections are going to be put in place.
Is there someone other than you are,
I are doing it but you need,
you know,
you know you need someone who can figure that out.
You need someone who,
who,
you know,
like certain bands and people don't like other bands.
You don't need that.
And the reason you
know that is we've had two very large totalitarian regimes in your parents'
lifetime or your grandparents.
I'm that that dictated that there was only going to be one mode of thought and
one reality.
And if you thought different,
they might kill you.
Nazi Germany,
the Soviet Union would,
communes were Red China to where,
where there was a very narrow band of,
of free thought you could have.
And the attempt was to get everybody on the same page.
And you think,
because hit and I think probably misquoting Hitler here,
that the idea was to have one brain running the society instead of all these
brains.
And if you had an entire people who could then be the muscle force for one will
then you we're going to be more efficient.
And he thought Hitler thought he would,
they were much more efficient than we were because you have one guy saying,
okay,
we're going to all do this and then everybody does it as opposed to us.
We're all this chaotic stuff and you know,
doing everybody moving in their own direction and in the theory of capitalism,
that's a good thing.
But in all these totalitarian regimes,
that is a lot of wasted energy and a lot of wasted effort.
And who made you qualified?
It
decided that you wanted to do,
yeah,
when I was saying by saying the only way to have what I mean is the only way to
have a society that works well then you have a bunch of things happening is you
have to have disagreements.
You have to have a few on variety of people want it to see if you want Freeman.
But there,
there should be freedom.
I mean obviously right?
Everybody sort of tee shirt that says that.
I think one of the problems that we have really first and foremost is that no
one is qualified to be president.
The idea of being a president is a joke.
The idea of being a mayor is a joke.
The idea of being a governor as a joke,
it's too big.
It's too big a task for any one person.
So to have one person just be a figurehead,
one person to be a spokesperson,
that's ridiculous.
It shouldn't be that anymore.
So one person,
the one mind the internet.
Okay,
I'm just going to say what's the alternative?
The Internet.
The Internet's the alternative and then,
okay,
well,
well what about all these crazy people?
What about all this fucking nonsense?
What all these nuts that posted in the internet.
Then we have to deal with the real issue that humanity faces.
The infrastructure of humanity itself is incredibly flawed because we ignore a
bunch of crazy people.
We ignore impoverished people.
We ignore the weakest link in our community and we're pretending it's not our
community.
If we become a global community,
we are going to have to address that.
You're going to have to address who,
what shitty human beings are making shitty human beings to grow up to become
youtube posters.
Those Youtube commentors crazy assholes and help this girl to die because she
sings a song.
You've
got me thinking about something that there's,
there's two basic philosophies you could have in our kind of political system.
One is the superior human being,
in other words,
a society of 300 million people.
In the same way you would produce some great Olympic athletes who were superior
at this or that physically you will produce some people who are superior in
terms of governing,
in terms of education,
whatever it is,
so that they can be our representative and do a better job than we could do
ourselves.
Well,
you could go back to a concept that is from ancient Greece,
although it didn't run like this in ancient Greece and say that the Internet can
be the facilitator for this and say,
let's vote on every individual decision.
Forget senators for get congressmen.
We have an internet.
It can be like American idol.
You could say,
hey,
should we go invade Afghanistan?
Get on your Internet right now and vote and we'll tell you what the tallies are
later.
Although it might be like that show that you said you were on that one time
where the votes didn't really count,
but a might be a great way to say,
hey,
everybody wanted to invade Afghanistan 99.9% wow.
Yeah,
but you know what I mean?
Is it that the two philosophies are really at polar opposites?
One is that would you actually trust the United States as you know it today to
make those decisions any better than they're made now or or would you say,
listen that and and fill in the blank.
X,
we might pick different people,
but I would let that guy be president because he do a better job than the
current crop of people.
If I could appoint him,
no,
it wouldn't be for me.
It wouldn't even be a politician.
I'd find some guys,
you can't have the system we have.
It doesn't work.
This is my point.
If you want to try to like keep patching it up and keep pretending that there's
any logical reason why.
If you started from scratch today and we're trying to design a political
infrastructure,
the ability to exchange information that we enjoy today,
you would never have one person.
I agree with that.
Well,
I don't know about that,
but I would definitely,
I think it's,
I think it's a ridiculous position first of all,
and I think the idea of people who are wise and older and maybe perhaps
information,
having information information,
but without any ulterior motive,
like people that really genuinely want their community to grow to be a safer
place.
People who want to figure it out,
how to relate the people who don't want to be a police officer.
Do you want to be president?
Absolutely not.
Okay.
You have a job.
You know,
here's the thing you are,
if you're what they did.
See the thing is president,
it's no one is qualified with it shouldn't be a job.
Let's talk about decentralization.
The problem might be that we have a government built for 13 states and small
rural in a much shorter population.
What if we said,
listen,
that's the problem.
And I talked to James Burke of connections and he said that the Internet is
going to make,
you know,
in the old days,
um,
it's almost like building monopolies.
We talked about entertainment companies conglomerating because they needed to,
in the old days,
you needed to,
it made you a stronger,
safer country.
But now with the Internet and the ideas and the,
maybe decentralization becomes the answer to some of,
I mean,
you can,
there's also the,
the idea that people were trying to organize to avoid tyranny.
The reason why a state will pass a law that the federal government doesn't agree
with this because the state disagrees with how the federal government is
dictating their freedoms,
right?
So those,
like people like in Colorado that vote on matters,
marijuana being legal,
they band together and say,
hey man,
look,
we're,
this is our land.
This is where we live.
And we think it's cool to do here.
If you,
if there was a bigger argument,
if you guys want to come in and prove to us that you could sell oxycontin's
every fucking cvs,
but this shit is illegal,
you're going to have to make,
you're going to have to make a point because we haven't,
we now have a state law.
This is an age old question that remember that before we had the government,
we had,
we had
something under the articles of confederation and the articles of confederation,
the earlier system.
The argument against it was that the federal government didn't have enough power
and that the states could get away with too much,
including things like maybe a Connecticut should be able to print their own
money and so you,
you get to this thing where we're where that wasn't working.
So they went the other direction and then there was a time Joe,
where we weren't called the unit when when people would say the United States of
America,
now they say the United States of America is doing something.
It was considered to be such an agreement between a bunch of states then until
about,
I want to say 1,918 90 they would say the United States of America are doing
something.
In other words,
talk about the states as though they really,
it's not a country,
it's a confederation of states that agree to be together because it's working
for them.
The civil war screwed that whole thing up and that's when you always get these
guys like rand Paul always has like five guys working form of they,
I still have the confederacy if they want to.
He's got some secret white people working for him.
Huh.
You know what's scary though?
What's scary though is that if you're like me and I don't agree with any of
those kinds of things,
I understand their point of what they're saying though,
which is that the,
the,
the racism and the slavery and the Jim Crow laws totally screwed up.
States' rights because it's like a child who you say you can stay out as late as
you want cause I trust you.
And then they stay out until five in the morning and they come home all drunk
and you go,
that's it for you.
You're not going to be staying out.
I do.
And that's what the stage did.
They abuse the states' rights things and,
and the federal government now gets to run while where you could go,
God,
maybe we,
maybe we could trust the states to be okay again.
But what you'll have happened is the states that are like us,
we'll totally use their things responsibly in the states we don't like.
We'll be,
you know,
no voting rights and they'll be doing all the geo,
we're putting people to death for marijuana use in South Carolina because that's
the way we like it in rock and Dana.
So you wonder if it would work,
but at the same time you go a little decentralizations starting to sound kind of
good.
Well,
if only for the complexity reasons.
Yeah,
very good point.
And what I,
what I meant by,
it's good to have states to fight against tyranny.
Ultimately,
it'd be really nice if there was no tyranny and it was really nice.
It wouldn't be no tyranny.
Then we should really stop looking at anything regionally.
And that extends to states,
extends to countries,
and extends to the nation.
He's,
why do you even have to have,
because you may have people that are like you,
500 of them are in Tennessee.
Why should Tennessee be Tennessee?
Why can't it be the Joe Rogan nation,
which includes 500 people?
See,
that's the real problem.
You name it after a dude and he's going to fuck everybody.
And then when you're gone,
it's the Brian Redmond nation,
and it might be run totally differently.
Everybody.
That's right.
It's not a good idea.
The son of God and everybody's wife and his,
you can't eat,
sign American rock that rock that we can't have that kind of power and people
feel,
do they fuck it up?
But the problem is that the decisions still have to be made.
So someone's got to have the voting
American article.
But if you were going to,
if you were going to,
and we'll,
after the swear folks wouldn't get into history,
there will be no history.
If you were going to design a new civilization,
if you could like stop everything that we're doing and look at it in terms of,
okay,
here's the resources,
here's the humans that need to be fed.
Here's the things that need to get done to make our life a better place.
Um,
what's our conflicts?
You would find out the conflicts.
So it's almost the scene conflicts that have always existed.
Control over resources.
If one person has an oil well that punts persons just sucking billions of
dollars out of the ground.
And then there's the hippies,
they're like,
man,
who says that is his man that oils the earth?
Why should you be able to profit off that?
And then the Breitling people would say,
well,
he's the one who built the infrastructure.
We built the machines.
He designed to be a fucking dirty hippie.
Of course he gets deal all the oil and it gets to be a weird situation where you
go,
okay,
how do you manage those conflicts?
Everything else is bullshit.
Lobbyists.
Hello Shit.
Get the,
now there's,
there's two ways you look at it.
One is the ways they'd done in the past,
which we talked about direct democracy,
you know,
you could do with it,
let's vote on who gets to own the oil well or whatever.
Then there's representative governments where you say,
Joe Schmo can be my guy and be be the one who votes.
Uh,
for me ether as I tell him too,
which some people believe our government's supposed to do or because I trust his
intellect and his judgment and so he'll go do that.
Um,
or some idea we haven't invented yet,
and I keep trying to tell people this all the time,
the attitude they have is that every kind of government that's ever going to be
invented has been invented.
And our choices are the ones we've had.
I'm truly have the belief system that they are going to be kinds of governments
we haven't thought of yet.
And the Internet might be a perfect example of something that can facilitate
that.
I don't know what they would be and they might be an evolution of something
we've already seen or they might be something totally wicked and weird,
but I think that that might happen.
I think it already is an ally.
Maybe the Internet is judging their passing judgment.
And a sentence on George Zimmerman and a lot of ways this Trayvon Martin thing,
and I don't mean everybody,
but there's a percentage of people that have decided that that guy murdered that
kid and he got away with it and they're writing articles and making videos and
attacking,
attacking all day.
And that is in a large sense a punishment.
And in a huge sense,
it's not even being thought of.
Cause everybody thinks,
well the guys out there wandering free the fuck he is.
Could you imagine how terrifying it is?
And I'm in no way supporting this man and no way I do.
You know,
I'm,
I'm not casting any judgment.
I'm saying imagine how much hate that guy feels everywhere he goes.
Every time he sees a black face,
he knows it's very likely that that person is very mad at him.
Or might even want to assault him or even possibly kill him.
There's some people out there that hate that guy and that's all based on the
judgment of the Internet.
That's all based on the judgment of the people that have access to the
information.
They've collectively agreed that they hate that guy.
There's a judgment,
but I'm not comparing that.
You had to,
all these disclaimers we have to have,
I'm not comparing this case.
The Oj Simpson thing seems very similar to me then that was basically
pre-internet what it is,
but it was just distributed differently,
but it was just as effective in terms of the public consciousness absorbing it.
Yeah,
I think so.
But now I think,
I think he gets
it like more readily.
Here's the opinions directly from,
you want to have him run into a disaster.
Go Jay could put blinders on and go to a restaurant and pretend I was acquitted.
I'm looking for the killer.
You know,
he could,
or he could lie to himself about how many people wanted,
you know,
something bad to happen to him.
We can't really lie to yourself when you read the comment.
Yeah.
And even though that sucks,
it's good.
I Hate Zimmerman,
Rogan and car and I hate them all people hate.
There's a lot of people that hate and that's something that we're going to have
to address,
uh,
just as,
as a,
as if you,
if the human organism really is a super organism,
the human race,
you're,
it's just like a person who has a cavity that's trying to ignoring it.
If you've got a bunch of crazy people in this world,
you've got a bunch of mindless people that are doing horrible crimes.
You have to address that somehow or another.
Collectively we have to stop trying to get a Tesla s and address underlying
behaviors.
The line,
this is the Gi Joe Rogan Dan Carlin line where I don't follow you,
but you weren't you,
you were in my mom's camp though.
So you've got some good company,
but it's just got told is data we need to tell me.
I get told,
he just got put on this camp that says we humans must evolve past all this
stuff.
And then there's the camp that says no,
what you see now and what you have seen since the beginning is what we are.
And you have to build systems with an understanding that this is what we are.
And this is the old history thing.
The only reason you learn from history is because the one thing that's not
changing in those history books is [inaudible] else changes.
But you know those guys in the Roman play,
that's the,
the,
there were togas on,
but they were us.
So like when you read about the stories of Yon Van Bliden nor,
and listen to you talking about it actually,
yeah,
I go,
that's David.
Correct.
That's right.
The same guy.
And so my point is that I'm not willing to try to build a society based on the,
okay,
as long as we evolve,
this will work.
Because I don't think that's happening.
I see your pessimism and I totally understand.
I live on the pessimism.
Just so you know,
I think if you look at human beings from the time of neanderthal wars with the
fucking vikings and the,
you know,
the Crispian Shaw showing up and sing a pile of bones,
it looks like a snow capped mountain in the distance.
Cause the Mongols got there first.
That's where they had abandoned roads because there was so many decaying bodies
and fat who was blocking the road yet walking the roads and everyone was dying
of diseases.
I mean that,
that all happened.
Just a few.
Let me,
it was a 900 years ago and let me just tell you haven't heard the Austin Front
podcast we did yet.
No,
I haven't heard it yet.
I'll tell you the way it starts.
The Oss Front podcast that we did,
we just on the war in the eastern front,
which not enough,
have a load it up.
Most of the people in the West don't know about this.
We learned about d day and all these things we did,
but we were on the periphery of that war.
That war really happened between the Germans and the Soviet Union in the east.
And there's a book called aftermath by Donovan,
which is a fascinating
book where he goes to these battlefields today and sees what's there.
It's like a Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
And he goes to this woman,
he goes,
it,
it's,
it's not as good as that obviously,
but he goes to,
he goes to the,
goes to this,
uh,
he goes to this,
this field in the middle of the steps.
So it's where the Mongols worse,
it's this wide open expanse with no hills,
no mountains and everything.
And A,
and a Russian guide takes him here and it's covered in snow.
And the Russian guide tells him to put his eye down on the ground.
So he's viewing it at eye level and he says,
as soon as I do,
and as soon as my eyes adjust to the sun and the snow,
I see things sticking out of the ground all the way miles,
often into the horizon.
And then he realizes their bone all as far as the eye can see.
And then he goes and they start walking in their bones with boots on them and
belts and everything.
And it's because so many people,
this is where Stalin Grad was and the last stand of it and it,
it's miles and miles and the Sobey,
it's just in bury anything.
They just coordinate the whole area off after the war and let everything stay
where it was.
And since he wrote that book and the Soviet Union has fallen,
the treasure hunters have been going through these areas because they can sell
daggers and boots and metals and all these things they find and they have been,
you can go online and see where they've picked these places clean.
But I mean it's unbelievable.
And this is now,
I mean this is,
they're there and the farmers shit still there.
Yeah.
And the farmers and there's no pain.
There's no pictures of Soviet Union wouldn't let them take pictures.
So there are how many miles,
oh for,
and not just here you go to this one valley and it's all there and then you
drive to another valley.
And there's another one because of what they would do is they would just Google
maps.
No,
I don't.
Good question.
But what they will do is they will,
they would close these rings,
right?
They would surround the look for it.
If he was gone,
well call us Soviet bone fields,
Soviet bone fields.
What happens is as their,
as their surrounding these Germans,
they're closing the ring tighter and tighter and then they use artillery and
just destroy these pack Germans who are packed in,
you know,
a pocket of maybe 15 miles by five miles.
And they just end.
The Soviet is just left him there and they left their own troops there.
And so when you,
when you hear this story of the oss front,
this is recent.
And those people did,
the farmers used to have to take the tractors and pile up the bones in the
corner of their farms so they could plow the fields.
You know.
So this is,
and you go to France,
what time period is this?
What you in 1940540440 three.
And if you go to France today,
this is also in Webster's book,
which is a fabulous book.
Aftermath.
You should go get it.
Um,
he talks about the first world war where you go to France today and they had
giant parts of the most fertile parts of France that are still cordoned off.
You can't go near because there's 30,000 or something,
artillery shells,
you know,
per square,
you 20 feet or something that come to the surface because the weather brings
them up.
Some of them have poison gas in them.
They're all rusty and d stabilize.
And the French have squads of people who collect these as best as they can all
the time.
And then like every month,
take them off the coast at low tide and blow 'em up and they lose like 50 or a
hundred of these guys every year who do nothing but dig up this artillery that's
made huge swats of friends in 1914 to 1918 uninhabitable.
And it's still there.
And so when you talk about how long ago some of this stuff happened,
a lot of this stuff didn't even happen that long ago,
but people don't even know what's out there.
So your thoughts on seeing horrific things that have happened like that are that
you look,
it's just a matter of the shit hitting the fan here.
Something going wrong.
US getting into some sort of global conflict that's happening at your doorstep
and we would revert right back to,
here's my theory.
I almost feel like pressure builds up.
Like you know,
you know in California we used to call it earthquake weather,
right?
You get this thing where you just felt like,
okay,
there hasn't been an earthquake and a long time you can almost feel the ground
getting ready and like it just,
something's got a break and the first world war was that way.
Everybody kind of saw it and something's going to happen,
something getting boom,
it happens.
I think that's what happens.
I think.
I think the tensions build up.
Things get frayed,
the systems begin to degenerate.
People start getting rouse d and then something happens and everybody goes
Berserk for awhile.
And in Europe used to happen like every hundred years.
You know,
after they beat the hell out of Napoleon,
they sign this congress of Vienna and they get this great system going.
The system goes for 100 years until it phrase,
and then once it phrase it,
I'll explodes again and an even bigger war.
And then the first world war leads to the Second World War and it's just the
tension and the stress get to be such a degree that things just collapsed and
explode.
But when you have an earthquake,
it takes the tension away for a while.
It's like,
it's like whatever the seismic pressure that was building up,
you know,
is deep pressurized for awhile.
Everybody can exhale and then it slowly starts ratcheting up again.
I think that that's what happens.
We hit these periods where earthquakes just happened.
Do you think that this is a,
that society today is a safer place though than in the 1940s and certainly then
the 1200
I don't know.
You don't mean literally,
I don't want to pretend that I do.
I,
I think that perhaps we're in one of those period,
there's an argument about,
you know,
cause you know I'm an anti global,
I don't think the United States should be in 147 countries.
I'm against all that.
But the people that argue with me about that,
so to give fair due to them,
we'll say that the reason we don't have that kind of stuff happening is because
in the periods of history where you've had great powers,
it was Great Britain before us.
There have been other powers before that,
the Roman Empire,
whatever you want to say,
that they keep the lid on these things that they provide the stability that when
they're not there or when they choose to not do their job,
sometimes everything finally goes to heck in a hand basket.
So you're going to have these earthquake sometimes,
but if you have an overarching power that can sort of nip the earthquakes in the
bud,
it doesn't get as bad.
I don't know.
But that's what they always argue with me against.
I don't know that you can prevent them because I don't exactly know what causes
them.
I think it's a think.
It's just human nature.
Yes,
and that's where we get about earlier.
I don't think you can change human nature or the that you can.
You can change your own nature if you know what,
here's a here.
Okay.
If I want to think like Joe Rogan,
if I want it or my mom,
if I wanted to talk about it,
evolving it both.
Oh my mom,
you've got to meet my mom.
She's a crazy woman.
If you want to talk about evolving past this,
then maybe you could talk about DNA changing and some of the scientists who are
taught.
It's funny because you get right back to Nazi eugenics when you get to this,
but there is,
there's an opposite thought.
Well,
instead of creating the master race in terms of the strongest and the biggest
and then maybe creating a master race means getting rid of those human qualities
that if we had a choice,
people wouldn't have.
You've talked about madness.
Well,
what if some madness is connected to things in the DNA string or violence or you
know,
whatever you want to say.
These people that are,
you know what?
If you're born to be a rapist and you could get rid of that from somebody
DNA,
someone just got a new test to Dan Carlin.
You see,
my point is that if you want to talk about changing human nature,
it might have to be at the DNA level as opposed to hoping that people will just,
the reason why I disagree with that,
the reason why I disagree with that.
As you think it's vitamin I,
the people have changed.
I know that some human beings have evolved and what are some who
have societies but cannot?
What happens to one person happened to tu cannot happen to a group,
cannot have happened to our society.
I think the real issue is we're not making the best use of the information that
we've been provided.
We have unlimited access to all the answers as far as human behavior.
Good enough arguments.
Some of these Weirdos could be talked out of their weird and management and I
think there's a management of your own personal energy to 20 yoga classes and
that's a show.
Joe Kahn Karate.
It should be a part of your life I think.
I mean for,
I've always said that for boys,
I think that's something difficult.
Whether it's rock climbing or whether it's Jujitsu or whether it's a sport or a
a musical pursuit.
Something difficult is important because you have this overwhelming desire to
spread your seed,
not just sexually.
It's also spread.
Your ideas
should the overarching state mandate that it has now that doesn't ever work.
I think this should just be positive examples around.
I think the idea of government to me is not as effective in cleaning up the
neighborhood as a really well funded a little hippie side.
I'm telling you I'm a hybrid.
Yeah.
They got a lot of Hippie in me.
The hippie Jujitsu.
I'm the,
I'm the bridge.
Yeah.
Okay,
well I see it.
That's the hippies in the right.
My mother thinks bad earthquakes are going to happen and we're going to be
forced to pull together afterwards and that,
that will bring some,
a lot of people believe that that could happen.
And I remember after nine 11,
uh,
that big historical moment where people were really fucking Nice in New York.
It was one of the weirdest things ever.
I remember going back to New York,
we were there in 2000 and just maybe,
maybe of 2001 just a few months after nine 11.
And people were nicer than I can ever remember.
Nicer,
more engaged,
more tuned into each other,
more like more,
more appreciative of each other.
It was a completely different vibe.
So it lasted for a couple of years.
Then people turned conti again,
but it's like,
so they reverted back to human nature.
I had a kickboxing instructor.
His name is Shuki.
It's Sheekey's from Israel.
Cool motherfucker.
I think he's in back in Israel now.
Uh,
but he was a,
he,
he trained in Holland and lived in Israel and you know,
he lived in a fucking war zone man.
And this guy,
I went over his house for dinner once,
him and his wife,
they start dancing,
they bring out the Bongos,
their kids are dancing.
And I mean he's just like so festive.
You know,
they're having a couple of cocktails and not even drunk.
They're just like having a good time.
And so I said to him,
I said,
well,
I go with so many Israelis I meet are like look like so happy and fun loving and
like he goes because over there he goes,
you could just fucking die.
He goes,
People die all the time.
So when you're alive,
party,
party.
And that was his attitude.
It was like I had friends like that growing up and they weren't,
they've
done a universal response for that,
those types of situations.
But I think one of the possibilities is that you can appreciate life when it
becomes fleeting.
I think the problem with your philosophy,
and I'm not,
I'm not denigrating it here,
is I absolutely believe you are right.
And I think we all,
I mean if you had grabbed me at 18 and compared the 18 year old meet and now you
would say,
wow,
that Dan Carlin guy has evolved and he's,
he's a,
he's a better person in so many ways then he was there,
but I'm not human beings in the aggregate.
And when you think about all those people out there and you say for things to
change,
we all have to get better or it won't work.
And I'm thinking to myself,
okay,
I know which way I'm betting on this in Vegas and I go to Vegas and betting
against the human race because I've seen it operate.
Yeah,
no,
I see what you're saying.
You and I agree.
Almost complete adoption and now you're back into Nazi land where they say the
only way to get complete adoption is to mandate complete adoption.
If you give people freedom,
you're giving people the freedom to not evolve and there's a lot of people to
choose to not evolve option.
I absolutely think you're faster if you want to look at it in terms of,
you know,
what you've seen so far,
like these patterns repeating themselves over and over again from experience.
One would lead to believe,
but my answer to the big difference in the ingredient is the internet.
And I think that didn't exist before.
And I think the,
the ability to exchange information the way we,
we enjoy it now,
you can't factor in the influence that that's going to have on how people
understand the impact of decisions,
how people understand how behavior effects people,
help people understand the good in people as well.
Like the,
the ability to spread that and to realize that,
you know,
we think people are,
a lot of people like to think that people in Iran are somehow or another our
enemy.
But then you watch all these videos of like kids and I ran and people talking
about America and talking about the problems with the world and go,
oh wait a minute.
They're just like us.
They're just people.
They're just young people that have a different noise that they make for their
mouth that equals their words,
but other than that they're just people and that slowly but surely sinking in.
So this idea of enemies and groups and states and territories and countries,
it seems more and more ridiculous when the,
the global communications connection that we have really brings us all together
in a,
in a way that's never happened before,
not just in countries but in states and communities and slowly but surely we're
going to realize that we are conflicts that we have are all because of cavities
that we're avoiding.
It's all because of behavior that we're not checking at an early age.
It's all because there's zero emphasis put on managing psychology for children.
Z.
I've known nobody ever taught me in a think.
Nobody ever taught me how to like think positive and move forward and how to
treat people and be kind and that that it is actually
official places on the one part of that that I really can,
can,
can grab and hold that you said that I like about the children thing.
We did a show called suffer the children once where I examined something called
psycho history,
which is a,
is a,
is a line of history that a lot of people don't buy into and we,
and we,
when we did the show that way,
it's like Dan Carlin examines everything.
I mean it was,
I was over there basically talking to these guys and,
and,
and thinking about psycho history.
There's only a few people who do it,
but their contention was if you look at the child rearing practices that people
used to do in the good old days,
I mean 100200500 7,000 years ago,
almost all of it would be classified if you did it today as the abuse and the
attitude on the part.
I mean,
the assumptions that these people make is if you could actually raise better
children knowing what we know now,
understanding what we know,
you might actually change the human race because if,
if child abuse,
massive child abuse on a society wide level helps explain why the past is what
it is with all the violence and carnage and horrific,
then could you change that outcome by raising better children?
And that might have something to do with what you're talking about here and not
be Utopian where you say,
listen,
the children that were raised well in the past,
we're fine.
It's all these crazy people whose parents beat them with a chain that screwed up
the past.
What if you got rid of parents beating their children with a chain for the most
part?
Wouldn't society as a whole be better?
She gets eaten shitty people make shitty people and that's what it is.
So no one stops that chain.
So,
so again though,
how do you and,
and,
and at what point,
once again,
we get the problem is that you and I are noncoercive people,
but you get to a point where in order for our ideals to work,
somebody has to tell somebody you can't hit your child with a chain dude.
And that's coercive.
So I mean,
so at some level we're still talking about forcing people to do something that
they don't want to do.
And where's the line?
Well,
fort not necessarily forcing people,
but inspiring them to do.
I'm inspiring you not to hit your child with the changing out a way to raise
people that,
first of all,
making it much more voluntary when you have a child making it something that
you,
you know,
you engineer,
whether it's through better birth control or through better,
better education or through something,
there's gotta be a way to make it a little bit more difficult for an asshole to
be raising a person and fucking that person.
The problem is those people don't really realize that they're not the people who
should be having kids,
but will they in 20 years,
that's my thoughts will change the way we've changed the logo will change that.
That guy will go online and go,
oh,
I shouldn't be a one.
Well,
I don't think it'll be as simple as going online.
That's what my point is.
My point is that it'll become a part of us.
The Internet is not going to be something that you plug into.
It's going to be something that you experience all the time.
That's just a matter of time.
They're already doing that with these Google glasses thing.
You might be right and it's right and I think it's going to eventually work its
way into some sort of a contact lens or maybe even an implant.
There's going to be,
whether it's a hundred years from now,
whether it's a thousand let's let the pessimists play with your idea because I
think you're probably right.
I mean,
I can go there that you can't possibly imagine what it's going make matrix like
practically plug it into the back of your head and go.
But don't you see the possibility for the op?
Remember there was a great monkeys.
Okay.
An age thing.
Remember the monkeys episodes?
There was a great quotability Los [inaudible] on reruns.
Okay.
Growing up we saw it on reruns.
Remember there was the,
what were the TV you would turn the TV on and the TV would be looking back at
you and telling you to do things.
I mean,
in the same way that you see the freedom that a Google glass and the plug in all
the time can give you what if the person providing the message or the same
people that are telling us to go be at 147 countries all the time and go these
people in Iran,
they don't just speak differently.
They're all a bunch of terrorism.
I mean,
what if the person delivering the stuff in the Google glass or matrix thing and
the plug in the back of your head isn't benign?
No,
that's good point.
But I don't think it holds up because I think the accountability and
responsibility,
eventually there's going to be a trail from every action to the reaction and
we're going to be able to follow those trails and the people will be held
accountable.
It's the transparency that you see in your own life where the NSA's able to get
into your email.
We're talking to Edward Snowden and stuff right now.
I'm already talking about what's his face,
the fucking CIA guy.
The head Spook,
the general Patraeus who got busted because of an email exchange with a
mistress.
Can I one this backs up my theory though about if you're the head of the CIA and
you're know that you're cheating and you know what will happen if that gets out.
But you're the head of the CIA and you know what the CIA,
he knows it can find out how.
How'd that guy get?
I mean again,
it just,
you know what's funny is this is bringing it around full circle.
Cause I remember having this conversation the last time I was in,
in the house of rogue.
It's impossible to avoid that conversation because it's one of the most
fascinating we got.
Did we get it?
We get into to to uh,
to Gary,
hard to Musc.
We did.
Yeah.
It's the type of human being that wants to run things.
And I think that the idea of running things is preposterous.
I don't think anybody should be able to run things.
I in people,
so the collective,
all these people who want to run things,
how dare you.
You're not,
we the coercive don't want to run things.
Government are telling you who want to run things to sit back on your rear end
because you're not allowed to run things.
Even running scholarly things can be problematic.
And we were talking about that earlier that sometimes,
you know,
professors who have tenure can like,
they can dominate over ideas and not want to bend because they've been human
nature because it's ego.
They've been teaching one way for so long.
Some new information comes up.
They want to fight that fucking shit tooth and nail.
Even if it doesn't make any sense.
And it's not all the time,
but it's,
it happens.
It's just a weird thing that people do have power part me.
The funny thing is you're like at war with yourself cause half the time you're
like,
these people are so terrible.
Then the other half of the time we went,
I think we can evolve,
but I think it's human nature.
I personally believe that it's human nature.
Whenever any one person has ultimate power,
they abuse it and they're into sex,
violence and dominance and all and these priests and these are human qualities.
Do.
This is what makes the drama of history that that,
you know,
I always say to people,
I don't know how you can't be in the history because it's sex and violence and
backstabbing and it's all this stuff we love in,
in,
in drama,
but it's real and it's real because this is who we are.
Yes,
but let's go back to our scenario where it's four of us living in a village
somewhere.
Just the four of us,
the only people on the planet.
If all of a sudden Jamie decided that he was the king and Jamie was going to
cast rules and regulations,
Lord of the flies,
kill that mother.
That's where shit goes wrong.
We're shit goes wrong.
It's were one person's in charge.
I know shit going wrong is no person nature's screwed up man.
There's nothing he could do about that.
Is it screwed up or is it natural?
There's like only one way to get the pussy.
Sorry,
you got to control it.
But here's the funny part is that we actually,
we actually,
uh,
glorify that would say he's got leadership skills.
Yes.
He's a natural born leader and the rest of us should look up to that and allow
him to make the decisions.
Yeah.
He's a pimp and were pussies and we're shocked when that same behavior repeats
itself over and over here.
It was like exactly what you've been saying,
Dan Carlin.
What I'm saying is it doesn't have to stay that way and I really don't believe
it does.
I think that there's going to come a time,
whether it's a thousand years now or a hundred years from now,
or 10 where there's a complete total accountability and an evolutionary jump and
the way we look at things and the way we look at behavior and information to the
way the people in the future going to.
That's going to be just as big of a leap as the way we look at the Internet to
the people that lived in Martin Luther's time.
Look at the idea of translating the Bible into something that you can actually
read.
I hope you are right.
I'm all,
I'm off Norton,
but the idea,
I mean it sounds great to me.
It could all go wrong.
Don't get me wrong,
and you know,
the proof is like,
as you said,
it's wrong right now in several parts of the world.
You can go look in the Congo.
It's wrong.
I'm not so sure it's right here.
It's not right here.
I think we're all,
I think we're
on a precipice here where things could go either way.
After we talked about this last time too,
where I'm not convinced that we're not in an era where we're going to look back
on and go,
oh my God,
what did we do?
You know
when you start looking at the way Obama is aging,
like they all do,
they all,
they all do,
but when you see it again over and over again,
and he was one of the younger guys to get into office and just fucking look
youthful and vital and now he's just like,
he's just dried out.
It's weird.
It's weird to say it sucks them down like prunes.
It does mount of information that must come on that guys
desk everyday.
People witness people always.
If you talk about politics and you know you do talk radio or whatever,
you're always going to get these couple of people get all the,
you should run for president.
You should shut your mouth.
Do you think to yourself,
you go and kill people because there's not a president's ever been and hasn't
had to order something that requires and this,
but here again,
you get to the point where you go,
but I'd love to have a president that said,
I'm not going to go in there,
kill anybody.
I mean,
because you think about a guy like President Obama or any of these guys and they
know they want to be president and they know that they're going to have,
well,
I'll tell you a story.
Um,
I got summoned to jury duty once a,
normally I get out of jury duty in a very George Carlin like fashion where I
basically go,
uh,
I don't believe in convicting people,
but somehow once I made it through and it was a drunk driving case and they took
me in there and they ask all these questions like,
does anybody know how the alcohol,
blood level content and somebody can be changed and nobody raised their hand.
I'm going,
well,
you know,
you could eat and all these things and saying,
okay,
next question.
Does anybody,
and I raise my hand again.
By the fourth time I'm going to get diarrhea.
He looked at me like,
are you going to have a problem convicting this person?
And I go,
I really can't have that on my conscience.
I go,
you know,
society runs because people are willing to do this.
And I said,
yeah,
but not me.
I,
you know,
I really,
I understand that,
but I can't have that on my head.
Even for a drunk driving conviction.
And so you go Dan Carlin for president.
Yeah.
But you know,
and nobody could get hurt and it doesn't work in all breaks down and it's done.
You know,
he can't have a president.
I don't think there can be one.
I think in jury,
Judy,
right?
I mean,
the point is somebody has got to do that.
Eventually.
We're going to know who did what.
It's going to be in your head.
It's going to be unavoidable.
I think the way we record information right now is archaic.
We have these Shitty fucking biological,
uh,
hard drives and we record data,
we record memories,
we record ideas.
And sometimes people don't even remember what the fuck they did.
I bet if you went to Oj right now and got,
got inside of his head and got a memory of the actual event that where his wife
and her boyfriend was were killed.
I bet it would be chaos.
I would bet it was better.
I was with some people yesterday that I grew up with and they start telling me
stories of my own life from the time and I'm going,
what,
what?
And then a certain things I kind of vaguely remembered and you're like,
wow,
that was a memory that was a long gone,
you know.
No,
they've,
one of the recent discoveries that they've been able to show is,
um,
they've,
they've actually got proof that they can implant memories into a mouse is a new
study that they've done where they've actually shown that they can artificially
implement a memory into a mouse and just went back into my pessimism land.
That's how they're going to convict anybody who's dangerous in the future to get
an implant.
Do you know?
You actually,
I think it's going to go to shock your junk.
And send it out to women.
Well,
it's in your brain,
isn't it?
If it isn't,
it'll be five minutes from now.
I think the Dan Carlin would be the conspiratorial one big group of us.
I mean,
that's this knowledge that that's gonna.
I think you're going to be able to go back to this point right now and truth and
desperately in Mike Martin Luther King in the future,
they're going to email a child porn onto your computer.
They're going to bust you and you're gone,
baby.
Well,
I think it's going to be one.
I think it's going one further than that.
I think we're going to have an artificial way of recording things that's
indisputable and I think that you're going to have a hard time.
You're going to think you're going to have a hard draft for your life.
You're gonna have a hard drive for your life where your experiences are
translated into some sort of a digital form denier.
When you're 30 years old,
you go to resurrection and they shoot you down.
That's true.
Life playing out before your eyes.
That's what it literally is.
What's funny is we both see the same thing and you just see the good outcome.
And I'm thinking,
Oh my God,
do you know why?
Because you're a better person.
Because I experienced that and I know a above my own battles with the chimpanzee
DNA and my own,
uh,
ideas about becoming a more enlightened person or a more empathetic and kind and
loving person and myself who are still chimpanzees and will always be less than
ever my whole life.
Less than it was my mind.
They run into,
I've had a bunch of those guys just pass away too,
man.
They have all too,
if you,
if you surround yourself with a bunch of people that are trying to achieve
similar goals,
you can support each other and help each other.
And I think the community that,
uh,
I've been able to be a part of just with my friends,
shows me that there's hope for the idea of [inaudible] with chimps anymore,
but the chimps are hanging out together.
We're reinforcing,
have plenty of chimp friends who know how to manage their chimpanzee.
Like my friend Tate,
he's a perfect example of a champion.
Was at a manage being a champ.
He just trains a lot,
does a lot of Jujitsu,
does a lot of reading,
thinks a lot.
He's very thoughtful about it.
And then he's got his idea,
he's got his,
come on Brian,
he's got his idea of what,
you know,
what,
what constitutes being a good person?
What constitutes being noble?
You know?
And he pursues that and he,
and it's,
it's infectious and it's kind of contagious when you're around people that are
trying to do things along the sames lines,
same lines when they're trying to improve,
you want to improve yourself.
The problem is people imitate their atmosphere.
And if your atmosphere is living with the fucking mon goals,
if your atmosphere is you're,
you're hanging out with these savages that are wearing my skin jackets and chop
and babies' heads off for a goof,
like that's your world then this is,
this is where you live.
Try,
try stopping that.
Because human beings operates so much on momentum,
it's very difficult and you have to also have to have like a,
a time of,
of ultimate resources where you can actually stop and rest and reconsider how
things are being done.
Because otherwise you're basically pushing forward for survival every day,
which allows you almost a zero time for introspection when you're inside of a
city and there's 100,000 fucking savages on horseback with bows and arrows that
take a hundred and how many pounds to pull them?
Hundred and 47 Jesus Christ.
Ted Nugent uses a 45 pound compound bow.
You should see what those people who can do that over and over look like.
Oh,
they must be like chimps.
Sinewy monsters.
Yeah.
And then it hold onto the horses,
but just their legs and he's saying,
shoot from underneath the belly.
Wow.
Holding on with your legs.
The legs are leg.
It's like a,
like a Jujitsu guard did develop,
been doing it since they were two or three of these are like old muscles.
You know the crazy,
well,
it becomes a part of that though too.
They talked about how these people were just,
I mean cause it's so in their culture that it's been going on since they were.
So cause you know,
you know this,
I mean muscles are different and after you reached puberty then before,
but if you are using those same muscles from the time you're two or three,
it gets,
I mean they don't get large and bulky,
they just get like iron and sinewy and it's a whole different strength.
But it's also a neurological strength from doing a movement over muscle memory,
muscle memory.
But it's also a path like,
you know,
when you tie your shoes,
you know like that and you just tie your shoes but you don't think about it.
You just tie your shoes.
That happens in Jujitsu.
Okay.
And Jujitsu,
when you choke guys out enough,
before you even realize it,
you're choking somebody out.
You're like literally sinking up the choke before you even know what you did.
Someone spins you counter.
It all happens completely outside of conscious thought and it's,
it's happening with extreme strength.
Think about that with the Mongols a lot.
What you just mentioned yet.
No.
And,
and,
and that is the kind of thing where it was,
you know,
I remember you trying to sum up what we said.
What are you talking about?
Their viciousness.
And I remember thinking,
I don't really think of it that way.
I think it's more like what you just mentioned where it's more of a,
they don't even think about it then.
That's not life.
That's not vicious.
It's,
it's just a,
okay.
You know,
it's just okay.
I,
it's,
it's even when it's so ingrained in you,
you don't have to be vicious to do those things.
That's just okay.
You know,
choke them out.
Right.
Done.
You know?
I mean,
it's just,
it's,
it's just done.
Yeah.
They just,
it just,
it's a part of your everyday life.
You don't know any and no one's saying,
hey man,
wouldn't it be nice?
I'll cut that person's head off.
I did it.
I did it yesterday.
I'll do it again tomorrow.
It's like taking out the trash when you're dealing with like Gin China with the
story of how many did he kill?
They're a million.
Nobody knows.
They killed everyone.
This is a place that if you didn't surrender or if you didn't give in,
they often killed everyone.
And the attitude was,
if we kill everyone here,
the next place will give in more easily.
And there's a thing that we do today,
uh,
that people been really criticizing.
That's these double tap drones.
And the idea is that they shoot these missiles in and then when the people come
to collect the bodies in the sick,
they shoot in another round.
Mongols did that.
Yeah,
the Mongols did that.
And the stories are horrific mass and you,
you're fucking style of doing a podcast with is so dramatic and so intense that
like you feel like you're there for mother fuckers.
A trout tell you the truth.
We didn't do that with the last one and we didn't.
And people say,
well it didn't sound like one of your regular shows,
but you think if you want to do this,
like I would love to do this into the future.
And if you make the same movie every time and it begins the same way because I
love the way it begins and it eventually it loses its ability to ACDC song.
But I'm keep making the same fucking song.
So the point is is that when we go back to that style you like,
it will be a little fresh again and you will go,
oh yeah but,
but like the last one is a little bit more straight up,
a little bit less drama.
The net,
you know we,
we,
we take the same ingredients and we mix them in different amounts.
So if you go to like con or Ostrander,
you'll go,
oh that's the traditional formula.
But then we switch it up with other ones so you don't get tired of it.
Well you sort of have to do con the way you've done it.
Now that you've done it,
if it,
if there's anything like that,
it's so,
it's so dynamic the way you did it.
Like this is only one way to tell that fucking story.
You gotta tell that story the way he told that,
cause nobody ever,
ever told it before.
Where I gave a shit.
I mean,
I was,
I was interested enough to pick up a few books and look at some pictures.
And while the hunt fucking wolves with eagles,
how crazy.
Really crazy.
To this day,
they hunt wolves with eagles.
They have trained eagles,
they send them out and they kill walls.
I mean,
they're the most gangster human beings that have ever existed.
And the truth of the matter is,
is that the Mongols were just the,
the greatest version of a people in a culture that has existed since almost time
in memorial.
The huns,
the Turks,
I mean,
uh,
the skiff,
Ian's,
the [inaudible],
these are all the same,
you know,
if you think about like the way the native Americans lived on the plains,
right?
It's a culture that works because it's so meshed with the geography and the
climate and the ecology that once you find a system that works,
you stick with it because,
you know,
nature's harsh.
Exactly.
So the Mongols were that culture and those cultures were very influenced by
whoever was nearby.
For example,
if you're trading or rating the culture and it's Chinese,
you begin to look a little Chinese.
The clothes you rated were Chinese,
you know,
and,
and the,
the Mongol types that were in the West looked a lot like Russians or wherever
you were rating and trading with.
Right.
So the Mongols infused some of that Chinese culture into that step tradition.
So they were like Sioux Indians that have some Chinese in them now as opposed to
Sioux Indians that have some Russian in them.
And then they take that Chinese little little ti tint on them and go into a
place like Russia that's really backward when they invaded.
And Oh my God,
it's like the Chinese are like the first world during this time period and the
Russians are like living in,
in grass huts and it must have been just devastating.
Just devastating.
The Mongols went into Russia in the winter and the only people who do that
deliberately,
that is the craziest,
and they came from the Russians are really nasty.
If you tried to invade from the west,
talk to the Swedes,
talk to the Germans,
doctor,
the Poles.
It's a nightmare.
You lose everybody in those winters.
The Mongols come in from the other direction and Oman,
they just,
they,
it's like a tidal wave and they came in with all these sophisticated artillery
devices from China and the,
and the Russians have like these little,
it looks like Fort Apache.
They have these,
these forts that have like big logs and the,
and the Mongols come in with these stone throwing things and their shit shooting
human fat that they've lit on fire onto these would fats buildings and it's like
napalm,
that idea of human factor or human heads or they would send your,
they'd send your prints,
they'd capture your prince and then he'd be flying over the walls at you and the
mom.
The Mongols understood psychological warfare as well as anyone.
Someone needs to do that movie.
Fuck 300 someone needs to do a real,
cause.
I,
I saw a Mongol.
The Ganga is con movies.
Yeah,
I know.
That's how I feel too.
It's just like,
come on.
It's like a PBS fan is like the,
it was an ABC after school special.
Like he was in love with the girl,
you know,
choose me as your wife and listen,
if you read some of the current,
I mean,
there were some books out there that had been on the New York bestseller lists
where they make him sound like George Washington.
And I always say yes,
if George Washington were responsible for 50 to 70 million deaths or however
many it was,
I mean,
look,
yes,
the guy,
I mean,
they always say,
well look,
he started the renaissance and he,
he brought culture from east to west.
That's what they say about Alexandra too.
But if you're on the receiving end of Alexander the Great,
you don't care what he brought Hellenism to your society.
You weren't there to see it or hear doe,
your daughter's got tensioner.
You know,
it's a weird justification.
Well,
it's like we said in that show though,
historians always say,
well,
look at how much our modern society has benefited from what the Mongols did.
Yeah.
But we didn't pay the bill.
We ate the food.
But the people that paid the bill and who lived through it,
you know,
had to,
had to do those accounts that we read.
And then I always say,
they always say,
well,
you know,
those are very biased accounts because you know they were Mongols enemies.
I said,
that's like saying you can't listen to the Jews explain the Holocaust because
they've,
they're a little too vested in it.
You know,
it's exactly there.
They're really biased about that holocaust thing.
Will you also made really good comparisons between Nazi Germany and the Mongols
because of this very fact of history?
Is that history there,
you know?
Yes.
There is a fact that it opened up trade routes and the change.
That's where your mom benefits.
Good things did happen.
But you can only say that because it was from 1200 we don't know any of those
people that guide to make it by listen,
Hitler and the Volkswagen,
we wouldn't have Volkswagen's today man.
I mean,
and,
and someday that'll be a bigger deal.
And it was a really,
the way you were talking about that,
it was like you had a really like choose your words carefully.
Yes.
And you still do,
I just threw that out there a little.
Brian,
can we edit that?
That might get me in trouble later.
Yeah.
You,
um,
you have to like,
but the reality is a hundred years from now when people talk about the,
the concentration camps and people talk about it,
it will be just
like we talk about the inquisition today.
I think the fact that you had to choose your words carefully,
it shows what we're talking about.
There were places.
Can you imagine going to the people who literally watched,
I mean,
it was like a bomb going off when the Mongols hit eastern Persia.
Imagine going to those people and saying,
somebody's going to write a book someday comparing the guy who did this to
George Washington who they wouldn't know,
but just,
I mean,
this is,
you know,
he's going to be a great hero and you're going to go,
what the guy who just destroyed everything I could see for,
you know,
everything.
Men,
women,
everybody.
I knew died and yeah,
it's,
but that,
but to be fair to the mon goals,
that's a lot bigger part of human history.
They just were better at it.
They just did it on a higher scale.
There's a bazillion Mongol conquest in world history.
The Mongols are just the champions,
you know,
they just took it to the hot there.
The Muhammad Ali of the,
of the,
you know,
destroying the civilizations around them.
People.
There've been a lot of,
uh,
Floyd Patterson's,
yeah,
it's funny way of putting it.
Um,
if you,
you,
you compare,
uh,
the,
the cruelties of society,
there's always been great trends of cruelty.
There's always been horrible things that people have done to ensure that there
was no dissent.
It's just been a part of human history.
It's just the Mongols said,
okay,
let's ramp this bitch up to 10.
Let's,
let's see.
What's the craziest Shit
we are?
Some historians will say that some of it was timing too because there were guys
like Genghis Khan that arose in those same people's before the Byzantines who
were the,
the the successor state to the Romans were so good at,
at,
at like they had intelligence services that,
that were other tribes who would say,
listen,
you need to watch this guy.
He's,
he's amassing a lot of pot and the Byzantines and say,
okay,
here's 50,000 drachmas or whatever.
Make sure that guy doesn't see the morning.
And they would,
they would,
they would strangle these leaders on the rise in the cradle.
Some people have said that the reason Genghis Khan got to be Genghis Khan is
because the Chinese and the business and all these people were kind of at a low
ebb.
Otherwise they'd had that guy assassinated or taken out long before because the,
the major societies around them,
to them,
those are national security threats.
When you get these guys who were taking these tribes who normally fight each
other and pulling them together to become dangerous,
that's the scariest thing in the world to China and to the [inaudible].
The Byzantines into the Persians and they worked really hard to make sure that
didn't happen.
They would,
you know,
pay off one tribe.
The Russians were very good at this later on,
pay off one tribe to destroy another tribe.
And the reason the Russians dealt with the Mongols successors that way.
Exactly,
they would go to one and go,
I know you love our stuff.
You know,
we'll give you some,
I got a fantastic suit of armor for and 500 muskets if you'll go attack this
other tribe right now.
And,
and that's how they kept them apart.
The only danger was when they would come together and some people think that the
Genghis Khan thing happened because the people that normally,
you know,
and this goes back to what the people that say to me,
Dan,
the reason we don't have world war three is because America keeps everything
done.
Well in those days it was China and Byzantium and the eastern Persian,
but keep the,
the Mongols and all those people from coalescing and they were at a week cab and
the Mongols coalesced.
And look what happened of your isolation is
policies.
Dan.
Yeah,
because you're a fucking go into the step and deal with that.
We all got Genghis Khan.
Thank you very much Carlin.
You know it's,
it's really hard for people to even put themselves in state of mind that the,
those people must have experienced back when you didn't know what groups were
around the corner.
Like when they,
when people met the Germans for the first time and they literally didn't know
that they existed and they were scary as,
I mean like we with 300 units,
if you were going to make that movie today,
you have to make the Germans monsters.
So be like,
one of the beautiful things about your story was what we talked about of them,
the Caribbean Shaw sending these people out to go check out China and see what's
going on there.
If there's anything good for them,
is this worth invading?
He's,
he's never been to China and as,
as they're going like they don't even know what the fuck is there.
They come to this fantastic,
beautiful city.
Bigger than anything they've ever seen.
Never seen anything like that and someone fuck them up and killed all of them.
So they're like,
oh shit,
like didn't even know what the fuck was over the hill.
They got over the hill and they're like,
oh Jesus,
will you look at this?
We find an alien civilization on a planet that's amazing and somebody beat the
hell out of them and you just go,
I was scared of this civilization that got the heck beat out of it.
What the heck could do that?
Yeah.
They have nuclear bombs and light sabers and someone came and just decide to use
them for gasoline,
stuffed them into their space and not all of a sudden I'm really afraid.
Yeah.
I mean it's that those times when things like,
like when they first discovered the Germans,
when,
when you know a story on this a million times.
Yeah.
When,
when one civilization finds another one.
Listen,
I always wonder if,
if,
if the new world hadn't been discovered what it was by,
by Christopher Columbus and all that discovered in air quotes.
Always.
I do that.
Um,
what would the people in the northern part of the United States have fought when
the Aztecs or whoever was going to have a giant civilization and in Mexico or
whatever showed up on their doorstep.
That would have been the nightmare of all time for those poor tribal people.
You know,
it was interesting how the way you described it was like the depictions of the
those early cultures too is like these people at all this cattle and all this
milk and they got really big and strong because of that.
But they also did whatever the fuck they wanted.
So when it come to like real discipline and hard work and like endurance,
they didn't really have it.
It's like people always have like a certain amount of strength because of their
uniqueness,
but there's also a vulnerability to it.
Like Gingiss con,
he had all this money and all this riches in and he had some kids and the kids
grew up rich and they were all fucked up and eventually falls apart.
Well they used to say about the Germans when they were fighting the Romans and
the Germans were a young people,
young people to the Romans anyway.
And these Germans were being,
and the Celts to earlier even than that,
the Celts were like the earlier Germans to the Romans.
Um,
they're big,
they're strong,
they're ferocious,
but they lack endurance.
They lacked discipline.
Although the Germans could be very disciplined at times.
And they used to say,
if you could just get 500 Roman soldiers working together,
you could beat 2000 of these tribes been acting as individuals.
And,
and,
and that's,
and you know,
there are a whole historians who,
who basically said that it was civilizations organization that would compensate
for the lack of ferocity because civilization kind of weakens man.
And you don't,
everybody's not killing each other in the cities and you have laws and you grow
up nice and,
and these people are killing each other while they grow up and drunk and you
know,
the whole thing.
And to compensate for that,
it's organization and we form into units and we act under a discipline
commander.
And that compensates for the fact that they're much more ferocious than we are.
Yeah.
What was the Gingiss con quote about,
uh,
an army of donkeys led by a man,
Alexander the Great's got one of those two were where it's an army of donkeys
led by a lion will beat an army of lions led by a donkey.
That's how fucking off is that a Alexander the Great's quote?
Both.
They both,
they've got similar lines.
How much of those quotes do they attribute to great people?
It's just people making up shit about what they said.
At least you don't know.
It's not a weird thing,
but they used to say that,
uh,
I actually asked a great historian,
I don't remember which one I asked that question about how much of this,
because they used to say history is a bunch of lies agreed upon.
And you say to yourself,
okay,
how much of this stuff is real?
And archeology has helped a lot with confirming this or confirming that,
but it's not very good for statements.
Here's the part I love.
I still love the fact that there was a whole lot of written material that hasn't
been discovered yet.
Um,
we're going to find,
and we do find periodically these,
these,
you know,
you'll break into some basement somewhere and find 10,000 scrolls or something
and oh boy,
all of a sudden we can fill in because history is like a jigsaw puzzle and
historians are putting that to,
I'm not a historian by the way.
Let me emphasize,
I always emphasize that.
Um,
what,
what separates you?
You don't have a phd?
I have a degree,
but yes,
you need a Phd.
You that makes you a story.
Well,
yeah.
And,
and,
and basically what happens when you become a historian is one,
you really specialize.
So I don't think I would be able to talk about all these different things and
how they interact as much.
The other,
you're a history enthusiasts.
I always say I'm a fan.
Yes.
Um,
but I do have a degree in it.
Uh,
the,
the historian also studies a lot about what's called historiography,
which I find fascinating.
And which is what we're talking about here,
which is how does this stuff make it into history books.
And then how do we filter out Joe Schmoes bias when he wrote it,
when that guy wrote this horrible thing about the Mongols or conversely,
which happened a lot when they write this really glowing thing about the
Mongols.
How do I filter that?
Cause a lot of these guys you wrote great things about the Mongols were living
under the Mongols and had to show their stuff to the Mongols before it could be
published as has.
So here I got this stuff I wrote about Genghis Khan where I said he killed a
bazillion people.
Uh,
cut your head off now for writing that.
So you know the,
his,
the historians when they learn historiography are trying to learn how to compare
this source with that source and then filter out their biases as well as they
can.
And this can get crazy though later on when sometimes they say,
we can't trust anybody.
Okay then why are we doing history at all?
And it gets silly at a certain,
it's almost like every piece of information has to be disseminated with a
caveat.
You have to kind of say,
well,
here's what we do that,
yeah,
a lot.
In the last show we did,
I had to say,
you know in the show there's a lot of famous quotes connected to the Spanish
American war period and almost everything I read that was new.
Yeah,
we don't think they said that.
He had to say,
Ooh,
I love this quote,
but I have to say that people don't think they said it anymore.
Well,
I love the fact that you include that though.
That's a really enlightening part of the podcast because it sort of paints this
really accurate picture of what information is available to us.
Like when you're talking about Gingiss count,
they didn't know what fucking color his hair was.
No.
Some people say you had red hair.
Well,
a lot of the step people did.
So they had hair.
Oh,
well you know ginger one here
love.
I love,
love,
love.
When you,
when you do the history of China,
the Chinese were fascinated by it and it was a national security thing.
They had to know about these tribes on their border just in case they all got
together and combined.
And they would,
they would divide these tribes based on what they look like cause otherwise,
how do you know when,
you know,
like if he,
if you have a whole bunch of native Americans on your border,
how do you say these are the Cheyenne and they look like these but these are,
these are Comanche and they look like that.
So they're trying to help you understand,
you know,
because this is the,
and a lot of these tribes on the borders of Modern Day China have green eyes,
red hair,
blonde hair,
and then you get these weird mixes.
Cause they were combined and,
and,
and mate with each other,
for lack of a better word.
And they will find these tombs where the,
the husband is of Mongol type,
you know,
full of tattoos and everything.
But the wife looks Swedish because the,
these,
these tribes all had so many different ethnicities.
And it,
so by the time you get,
you know,
the early Turks are blonde hair and green eyes,
but maybe half Turkish sort of olive colored skin,
right?
So that after a lot of mixing,
they start to get a little bit more formed.
Like most of the Mongols either looked Asian or Turkish,
but you still have these DNA genes where every now and then you get your blonde
hair or your green eyes or your red hair mixed with Asian features.
And it's one of the things I love about him is that you have these types that
you don't expect to see mixing blonde hair with Asian features and just some of
the most wild that there's a famous picture,
and you've probably seen it on the cover of National Geographic.
It has an Afghan girl who's got the brightest,
greenest eyes you've ever seen,
but that's one of those ones.
But Afghan features in a dark hair,
dark skin.
But that's one of those wonderful mixes you'd get with the step people where you
go.
I never thought those kinds of people mixed together in large groups where you
would see all these different types in one tribe.
But you did most of the Mongols were probably Turkish.
That's fascinating.
And wasn't there recently,
um,
a discovery of Europeans that they couldn't explain it and we'll China and,
and,
and the Chinese eight this,
um,
it's,
it's a mummy in China,
a woman that's been around since I think the forties or whatever,
but she's a white girl basically.
I mean we would say today it's a white girl found in a tomb on the borders of
China.
But that's,
these tribes were talking about,
I mean they had,
they had some called the Woo sun and some called,
uh,
um,
the,
the UCI and these are tribes of people that the Chinese described in the BC era
as being white skinned because of the Chinese.
That was just one more sign.
They were weird as hell.
They have this white skin and round eyes.
It freaked the hell out of the Chinese.
Cause if,
if regular people look like Chinese people,
what the hell are these?
And they have yellow hair.
And,
and they sit,
described it as cat's eyes.
I mean to them this was wickedly alien stuff.
And today we would look at it and go,
wow,
that guy looks kind of like he's from Hamburg,
Hamburg.
Did you see this girl frozen in the ice?
Yeah,
they found this really incredibly intact inkind mummy of a woman who froze to
death while she was sleeping.
And it's,
I think it's 500 years old.
They said it well but,
but,
but I'll go one up on this.
That's rare.
But the way that they built these tunes on the step,
they were built so that the first frost would freeze everything in the tomb and
then they're,
they're found by archeologists today.
Lots of them totally frozen solid.
And they will take and boil water and slowly pour the boy and they will find
fabric which deteriorates,
that will find wood and they will find skin.
And that's how we know.
And there are photographs of what these guys did with tattoos.
They were the original tattooed people.
And we have their skin to prove it.
And so when you find these frozen tombs,
they're all over the place and you can see them.
They're in what's called Kurgans,
which are hills that they build on the step because they bury these guys and
then they pile mounds of dirt just like little mountains on top of them.
So you can't steal the stuff in the tomb and they're everywhere.
And they've only,
I mean,
tons of them.
Unexcavated still.
And are the people that live in that region now?
I mean,
have they recovered?
One of the things that you,
you brought up that was really fascinating was Baghdad and about how the
Gaviscon essentially killed everybody in Baghdad.
They,
they,
they wiped out or took her,
took them,
yeah,
they threw all their writing into the river.
And that people don't know that the,
the Islamic empires back then where some of the most,
oh,
Baghdad was maybe,
I mean other than China and you don't,
it's hard to compare and contrast.
But,
but I mean the Chinese were very sophisticated,
but this is a golden age in Islams history and it was centered around Baghdad.
And when Hello Goo,
one of the,
one of the grandsons of Genghis Khan takes Baghdad.
He shoots,
I love this image and you know you've already heard it,
but I mean they,
they don't have a lot of stuff around like big rocks to shoot.
So they build the siege engines and they just stuffed palm trees in them and
shoot the palm trees over the wall and they're just taken out people on the
streets of Baghdad with these palm trees coming over the wall.
And the Mongols were intense.
How insane is that?
They just fucking fondom with trees.
Any trees.
They killed everyone in Baghdad or took everyone as slaves or did whatever the
fuck they wanted to do with them.
They literally,
the,
they were saying that you were saying that the river was,
it's black
with the original sources that either either redwood blood sometimes are black
with the ink of,
of of hundreds and hundreds of years of Islamic civilized writing and
everything.
And to the,
to the people who wrote about this,
the Muslim chroniclers,
this is the tragedy of tragedies and,
and they absolutely exaggerate the number of dead.
I mean,
you'll read numbers where they say the Mongols killed 2 million people.
All that's a joke.
But they killed enough so that it was astounding.
And,
and to the people there,
he listen,
that's a nuclear bomb going off by muscle power.
I mean a,
a Gwynne Dyer wrote a great book once and did a PBS series to go with a called
war where he talked about the Assyrians doing this and he said they destroyed
Babylon as fully as had been done with an atomic bomb.
They just did it with muscle power and lots of people.
And that's what the Mongols did to Baghdad.
And he rain.
And believe me,
it sent a message to all the other cities because had Baghdad simply
surrendered,
none of that would have happened.
And so the other cities were going,
I think I'll surrender.
You know?
I mean,
that's kind of how that goes.
And that was the most advanced city in that area,
in that area.
Absolutely.
To this day,
much more advanced than any place in Europe at that time.
Could it be argued that they never really recovered?
Yes.
It could be argued crazy.
Yeah,
1200 yeah,
1212 1240 right around there.
And it still hasn't recovered now.
And certainly the population levels I was told only came back during the time of
Saddam Hussein and,
and,
and that's,
and so when people say things like,
well,
the Mongols spread civilization,
they absolutely did.
But let's remember the bill that was paid for the benefits that we got.
Think of that 700 years,
700 years of just,
because there's people out there probably saying,
let's be fair.
Part of the damage was that the Mongols,
you know,
to live in that part of the world,
right?
You have to have increased incredible irrigation systems.
And some of these irrigation systems were a thousand years old,
right.
And they just kept the ancient times.
They just rebuilt these things.
The Mongols either killed and destroyed all the people that kept that stuff up
or depopulated the whole area so that they fell apart.
So that if the Mongols didn't kill those people themselves,
by destroying the systems that kept those people alive,
they often get credited with deep populating those areas because all of a sudden
there's no water anymore.
The Mongols allowed,
you know,
the water systems to dry up to a point where now no one can live there.
So I mean that's,
that's part of how these numbers get so huge too.
It's just insane to think of how many people were killed by the most manual
methods.
No muscle power muscle does the injection of metal into the human eye.
If there's a whole book called from sooner to Rome where these military
historians are basically writing books about the amount of muscle power that it
took to kill people and on individual levels,
and then,
you know,
doing math to multiply,
you know how I mean,
it's the,
the,
the numbers and the figures are incredible.
But the sophistication of early armies is something that's always fascinated me
because we consistently downplay it.
When you think about this today without computers,
without iPads,
without even sophisticated calculators trying to put together 30,000 men
organized as an army and feed them and water them across deserts and all this
without any of our modern stuff,
we wouldn't even know how to do it today if you said do it,
but you can't use your computers.
And it was amazing how they would set up these points where like they would
funnel armies into areas and then they'd have like burning pots that would
obscure the vision so that people would run into this area where they were being
funneled into a kill zone.
And then when they got there,
that's fucking smoking.
Pot's and arrows are flying from the mouth.
Guys.
They'd send guys ahead of,
they'd send guys to go to these towns and scream and yell.
The Mongols are coming.
Oh my God,
you don't even know what they did.
And these are Hmong goals working for Genghis Khan who did that.
You know,
you can't believe what they did to this other city and spreading the rumors so
that by the time the Mongols got there,
these people were shivering in their boots.
You know,
they were just scared to death.
And so when he say something like,
listen,
I'm very tolerant of all religions,
I won't,
you know,
just,
just surrender and become part of them and it'll be great.
A lot of these places,
I mean,
truthfully you can argue,
and I bet Genghis Khan where he here today would argue that he saved a lot of
lives.
This is the same attitude with the atomic bomb.
Yes,
I destroyed Baghdad,
but it kept me from having to destroy 500 other cities.
What would the body count?
B then c,
Genghis Khan was a George Washington.
It's such a fascinating glimpse at our recent past and it's not real human
nature,
right?
We're back to human nature again with Jenkins.
Han evolve today.
If he just had the internet to hell and some Google glass,
it'd be playing starcraft.
They,
he totally,
he never get out of his room.
He had Darby crash and wouldn't be able to live like that.
Ideally today.
Someone would get you before you ever got that far.
Byzantines yeah.
Well it's also like a new army emerging,
like the United States is trying to lock down as much of that as is humanly
possible.
That's one thing that you have to
meetings with him.
I've heard him talk about this a little bit.
Oh yeah.
General Mattis and at Centcom meetings and where,
and they invited me.
Remember,
I think I told you this,
I thought I was going to get dumped in the Potomac.
I thought it was an organized assassination hit on me.
And the funniest thing about this,
Joe,
you'll,
you'll be able to relate to this,
is that they invited me because of the podcast,
right?
To this secret.
Not Secret,
but I'm not supposed to talk about who was there and,
but they had a list of the invitees and I remember saying to the guy on the
phone,
cause I've been to these things as journalists where there's like 200 people and
we drink wine out of plastic cups.
And you hear some general speaking of podium.
And I said,
listen man,
I don't have time for that.
It better not be that.
He goes,
no,
it's you and 11 other guys.
And he goes,
you'll recognize the names of most of them.
And I was like,
okay.
So I get there and everybody gets a printed handout at the Centcom secret
meeting of who,
of who,
who else was at the meeting and all of these,
do you have to about this shit should just stop right now.
I can't,
I'll show you a picture later.
Uh,
but,
but I can't,
when I couldn't do,
I can't tell you who was there,
but I'm looking at the list of people that everybody's got doctor this from this
institute bill rights and all these mass.
And then Mister Dan Carlin podcaster and I thought all these other people have
to be so pleased to be in a room with me,
you know,
and,
but I was listening to what they're saying and talk and look,
I already understood a lot of this stuff,
but to have it confirmed by being in the room with these people talking about,
okay,
how do we handle this situation if this area of strategic interest is shut down
and you're sitting here going,
okay,
these guys consider it their job to run the world.
They're tasked with running the world that if there's any choke points that oil
goes through,
that's our job to prevent anywhere in the world.
And you just sit there and go,
how do you dial this back?
How do you tell these people,
listen,
guess what?
We're not going to police this.
Persian Gulf choke with the Strait of Hormuz is no longer our responsibility.
They would look at you like you were from Mars.
Yeah.
They were like,
you're from Mars.
Like you're an idiot.
You don't know what you're talking about and you're from Mars.
You silly liberal.
That's it.
You hit these silly,
silly hippie you think everybody's going to be and everybody's getting evolve
from the Internet.
Right?
Carlin?
I see there's a certain amount of pessimistic reality that they have to embrace
and,
and being in the military at all because you've,
you know,
you've seen it,
you've been to war.
Like anything else,
you're in your own bubble where everyone is talking like you are right and
you're not hearing a lot of,
you know,
hippy talk and,
and so it's a really,
I mean when you hear something like that,
who is this?
You know,
if you've been at any of the meetings,
Carlin,
you would know the threats were really facing and I can't tell you what they
are.
You just trust me.
This is a bit of a stretch
comparison,
but what Brian was talking about earlier about friends that watch grizzly man
and don't know that he's gay,
like Comedians,
all of us together like this shit comedians.
If the people that we hang out with like look at this motherfucker like this is
immediately going after it,
those people and laughing about it and thinking it's funny.
Whereas if we're a group of Mormons,
we wouldn't have the same ones
is that we always there.
They used to do this and then this is,
it's a strategy.
They used to do it with the Simpsons really early on when they were,
they pretended like they were writing a show for kids and if you were a kid and
watching it,
you got it.
But on another level the adults were going,
Whoa,
I just got that joke where you,
where you're,
you're doing a show that's tiered and the same show worked for several different
audiences,
but the,
the one audience that doesn't understand,
maybe,
I don't know the show,
so just I'm playing along with you here,
but he's gay,
he's gay.
Oh,
how funny is this?
But the other audience is going,
oh no,
I love it.
He's gay.
What do you mean he's gay?
Know working on a number of different levels for different audiences that only
get what's what's geared toward their level
and amongst these folks to tie together the military people that are running the
various branches of the military.
Like the idea of the is not going to be in a war.
What the fuck are you even talking about?
[inaudible] do you live on?
We're out there getting shot at every day.
We're dealing with the IED attacks were in Kandahar this week.
You don't even know,
Dude.
You want me on that wall?
You need me on that wall.
You can't handle the truth.
What's the worst thing that's going to happen?
You lose a little Dick pics on the Internet.
You know?
That's the type of shit the NSA spying on you.
What do you got to hide and bitch?
Okay.
Do you realize how protective people,
Jesus Christ,
some gorilla [inaudible].
You can't handle a row buying grass fed grass fed show at this point.
You don't.
You want to Genghis Khan coming out.
You know that we're keeping that.
Yeah,
they,
I mean there is that argument,
right,
that this is the best of all the possible evils than if you look at all the,
the North Korean regime.
You look at it.
Let me tell you how weird I am.
Here's how,
and this,
I hope this is what people like about the political show.
I can see that.
I can understand that.
I'm not so,
you know,
I think,
I think part of what's wrong with talk radio is that every host has to say,
no,
this is,
this is how it really is everybody else's work.
I can see that and I could be wrong.
Um,
you know,
and I think,
I think if you factor that into your thinking,
it's important that,
look,
there's a possibility that that's all right.
That's all true.
And,
and factor that into your thinking when you come up with your own political
ideas,
put in failsafe idea.
Say,
listen,
I believe it's a pretty strongly,
but it might be be.
And if it's be,
here's my backup plan.
Well,
I've had a chance to see a lot of conspiracy theories that I know have no basis.
In fact,
when it comes to not just the show,
but mixed martial arts.
Yeah.
Because I do the commentary for the UFC.
I have seen so many elaborate schemes that people think are in play to make a,
you know,
a results happen the way she wants them to.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I'm sure that stuff has happened before,
but what I know to be an absolute undeniable fact and then seeing all these
elaborate conspiracies attributed to these events,
I so I'm aware as an insider,
yes.
So people who are outside,
and this is obviously very small nuance world,
the world of mixed martial arts,
but I think that's a trend that's a trend for human beings.
I think that the indicative too of a lot of other situations,
and I think that the big picture is probably infinitely complicated.
It's not as simple as the government doesn't want you to try.
The government's trying to control you.
That's right.
There's so much shit going on that it is just trying and they're all holding it
all together,
each other,
and yet they're absolutely care coming off each other and they're also dealing
with this new reality,
this technological reality and this and that is shaking things up.
Did you see the Michael Hastings video that was released today?
I did not,
but tell me about it cause I actually am Michael.
The whole Michael Hastings thing is important to me because I believe there's
this small group of journalists really doing the job of journalism and Hastings
was one of them.
So what,
what,
what did I miss the video of the car?
They got a video of the car from a security camera accelerating down the street
and then billowing up before it impacts.
No,
an explosion before the impact.
The car,
it looks like the car is driving and then there's a boom and then a boom.
So if you're a second,
if you're a Mercedes Benz right now,
you just have a reason all of a sudden to find out what really happened to
Michael Hastings.
So it's not your fault,
it's,
it's hard to tell what it is because it's not the clearest video in the world.
And it's black and white.
It's black and white.
It's a security camera.
It's,
but it's the things hurling down the street and you see this impact and on
impact,
there's a boom.
And then there's a giant,
huge explosion.
Let me,
let me point this out because this is,
this is truly the way I believe.
As much as I,
I might go there to some degree.
I literally can't believe that this guy was killed by the government or anything
like that.
And if he was,
then I don't even know what to
do here.
Let me put it to you this way though.
When I tried to tell myself,
Junkee video,
here's the video.
We're playing it right now for her to see if I can,
he's going to fly down the street and slam into a pole and there's no breaks.
Watch this.
Boom,
boom.
See that?
You see there's a boom and then there's a boom and there's a giant explosion and
they're a distance from each other.
So it's almost like the car blows up as it's
moving.
Here's the part that drives me crazy and I saw a couple cones in that too.
I used to,
I used ones,
Ufo things that fly.
Where do they call it?
Oh,
he's helping the case.
Mom,
Brian.
But you know what?
When I was at,
when I was,
uh,
here in La in news,
I worked for one of the best news men,
old dinosaur of a guy.
When I worked for him,
a guy named John Babcock won a bunch of Peabody awards.
Famous news guy here.
He taught me how to do news and his general principle was if the LAPD,
um,
doesn't talk about something,
boom,
we opened an investigation.
That's all it took.
It did.
We didn't have to know anything more than that.
They say,
they said,
no comment.
We were on it as a newsperson.
The question I have is why aren't they,
I mean,
look,
if you're a car dash sheen,
if you're some minor celebrity,
we shouldn't care about,
we're going to find out every little thing.
You know,
who was the,
who was the blonde chick that died in Bermuda or whatever?
Uh,
the diner.
Natalie Holloway.
No,
no,
no.
The one who was the stripper who married the rich guy?
What was her name?
Oh,
come on.
A stripper that married a rich,
but I'll come up with it in a second,
in a second.
Uh,
but I mean my point was as if you're some minor celebrity,
the media is going to uncover every last hour of your life and the whole thing
it if you're Michael Hastings,
where is the reporter?
Ben?
Who says here was Michael Hastings last 12 hours.
Where was he two hours before the crash?
I mean,
you know,
uh,
from what I've heard,
the guy hadn't had a drink in five years.
Um,
didn't do drugs or anything like that anymore.
but if,
uh,
oh God,
that girl's name is on the tip of my head.
I don't tip of my tongue.
I'll come up with it in a second.
Um,
but the point is,
is that normally you would expect the media to now go run past that guy's last
12 hours.
Cause that's going to tell you a lot about the situation.
Right?
No one's done that well,
I think crazy that no one's done it.
Independent Internet media has,
I think there's been many stories written on the fact that he was responsible
for in his articles,
getting generals fired.
No question.
And what was going on.
A big story.
I'm supposedly on the CIA and I'm betray us.
And it had something to do with Jill Kelly and had something to do with the
whole reason why he was fired in the first place,
allegedly.
I don't know the whole details on the story.
He was regularly had his life threatened as as many good investigative reporters
do.
This could have been anybody.
It could have been just some guy who hated him.
The other thing to remember that I was starting to get to though is that every
time I tell myself something like that's impossible from the government
standpoint,
there's a book called poisoning the press out there.
That's very good.
And it's about,
uh,
do you remember Jack Anderson that you've investigative reporter used to be on
good morning America always had some scoop and a Brit Hume from Fox News used to
be his assistant.
Jack Anderson was the deepest in Ames a ham.
I mean,
he definitely would take these investigative stories and I'm Jack Anderson and
his,
but he uncovered stuff that's,
that messed with people so much.
Um,
apparently there was a plan in the Nixon White House,
and this is on the record documents.
I mean nobody even debated where they talked about killing Jack Anderson
releasing sensitive information and one of the ideas floated was to do something
to his car,
including putting LSD on the steering wheel so it can be absorbed by his hands.
And two guys including g Gordon Liddy,
we're up for this idea and ready to go.
It was President Nixon that canceled it.
But I mean that idea got well past the early planning stages.
And you say to yourself,
okay,
if in 1972,
the president of the United States is even having people discuss this,
that blows my mind.
Forget about talking about Michael Hastings.
So you sit there and go,
what's possible?
Like I,
I'm not the kind of guy that can go there.
I just can't believe that the government would off this guy.
But there are so many questions and as a reporter,
you're not supposed to go in there and say,
I know what happened.
Let's see if the government killed him.
You're supposed to say,
all right,
let's see what his last 12 hours look like.
Let's get some toxicology.
Let's start to piece together things.
What,
we have no toxicology right now.
We have no statement from the LAPD.
Um,
some reporter in San Diego said that his body was returned in an urn without the
family's permission to cremate them.
I've heard that's not true.
Um,
I actually direct message that woman on Twitter,
that reporter,
and she didn't answer me back.
So I don't know what's true about that.
But the point you're trying to get some,
anyway,
the point of the matter is,
is that something's going on here.
And as a reporter,
you're supposed to go out there and begin to look into it.
What bothers me is that no one is,
I don't understand that because you know why?
Cause it's a salacious,
juicy story about a famous person.
It has all of the things that even if this wasn't,
you know,
a conspiratorial type story,
you would expect the media to be on just cause it's a conspiratorial story too.
Wouldn't you think that these people would be terrified to mean to journalists?
Fellow journalists,
it's just today,
five hours ago,
are now suing the FBI because the FBI I think had like 20 days to release the
information that they have on Michael Hastings and they didn't.
So they went over the time periods and now these two independent reporters or
the two guys next to be shot and murdered,
what are their names?
Uh,
Jason Leopold and Ryan Shapiro.
I don't know those guys.
And these guys are suing for the Freedom of Information Act?
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Some supposedly,
um,
uh,
Hastings,
his lawyer has all this information from what he was working on.
How'd you like to be Hastings lawyer right now?
Supposedly his girlfriend or his wife,
whichever the case is working on completing the book,
completing whatever he's working on.
Well,
again,
I don't like to be mister conspiracy theory.
What bothers me is that when reporters don't do their job,
like look into this
guy's last 12 hours,
I think it opens the door up.
I mean people are naturally now going to speculate and you're going to get these
wild theories about,
you know,
Michael Hastings and the Grassy Knoll,
which you don't have to have if the reporters can begin to debunk this.
The second thing that happens though is did you see wolf blitzer was hosting
some thing the other day with with,
you know,
the generals and I mean he looked like he was working for the government and you
just turn around and go,
okay,
the next question is do I trust journalists in air quotes like that to be
investigating something that,
so once they lose their credibility,
I've got to get some,
you know,
Matt Taibbi or some other guy who's a lot like Hastings to investigate him or
I'm not going to buy it.
I don't believe that you can consider wolf blitzer to be a journalist anymore.
I think he never,
this is the talking head that CNN keeps employing Wolf Blitzer.
Forget the journalist part.
How about he's just awful and there's nothing.
You could just see the video,
the really awkward video of the woman and asked her about God's saving her from
the hurricane.
She said she was an atheist and so Doug Stan hope organize donations for her
because she said she was an aide.
I've said before,
and I'll say it again,
and this is not an arrogant thing to say,
and I'll explain why in a second.
I could double CNNS ratings.
I could just give me CNN.
I will double their ratings in like 48 hours.
But the only reason I can do that is because they are so awful that,
you know,
the bar is so low that I could fire a few people there and their ratings would
double,
you know,
just be,
oh,
we'll put yours fired.
I think I'll turn CNN on again and see what's going on.
You know,
very important though,
um,
for CNN to have people that are willing to follow their agenda,
whatever the new Lee,
you're absolutely correct.
They're interested in getting these hard hitting.
No,
no.
You know how you know,
because they've cut their investigative budget down to nothing.
Well,
we had amber Lyon in who used to work for CNN and talked about her coverage of
Bahrain.
Yeah.
She says she did the special that they were in there exactly on CNN internet and
it was because they wanted to be able to park their military there in case some
shit went down with Iran.
So they wanted it to like sort of squash all this descent and all this.
So they essentially put together what was like a tourism piece.
But this is how,
and this takes us right to Snowden because this is where the government has
managed and they,
and this has been going on a lot longer than we think because they used to say
in the fifties and sixties that the CIA has a person in every newsroom in
America.
So this has been something that's been going on for a while.
But in the 70s they were breaking lots of stories that the intelligence agencies
did not like.
And as a Newsperson,
that's how you know,
news is working when the government and the intelligence agencies and all these
people that classify stuff are mad as hell at the news media.
The news media is doing its job.
When the news media is defending those agencies and not releasing the
information.
That's when you throw up your hands and go and and going after.
I mean,
when listen,
there are people that don't like Glenn Greenwald's personality.
They don't like a lot about him.
They think he's a grandstander.
All these kinds of things.
But what Glenn Greenwald did is what reporters are supposed to do and when you
watch reporters Slam Glenn Greenwald or Michael Hastings,
he took such crap from other reporters because he reported stuff that they
wouldn't report because they didn't want to burn a source.
That's when you go,
wait a minute.
You're priorities are totally screwed up.
If you're worried about telling the American people important things because
your source might not talk to you anymore.
You know the Breitbart story,
I don't like it.
And conspiracy guys who aren't reporters.
I mean,
that's right.
He wasn't a reporting that drives me nuts drive.
What's weird about the story is that the guy has a heart attack and then his
corner gets poisoned.
The guys corners poisoned or did he die?
What happens is poison territorial.
The guys are,
but,
but listen right away to your reaction,
which is fascinating.
We,
you're talking about a guy who has may be releasing very sensitive information
about very powerful people and you're like,
wow,
but it's a natural inclination.
I'm not,
I'm not saying you're incorrect.
I think a good reporter and not that I am,
but I can see when when I,
I didn't,
I know him when I see him.
I'm a good reporter,
is supposed to be a little skeptical,
but still follow the leads.
You don't want to report this as I bet John F.
Kennedy wasn't killed by Oswald.
Let's go and look in that.
You want a guy who says,
okay,
there are some questions.
I'm going to follow the trail of evidence and see where it leads me,
and a good healthy skepticism is good for a reporter on both sides.
You don't want to take anybody's word for anything.
At the same time,
you don't want to be a nut.
He don't want to go off into fantasy land.
Dead from arsenic is coroner was killed from Arsenal.
Okay,
well that is a little warrior.
The fuck man.
The two months after Breitbart's passing the corner that investigated the cause
of death.
Are you on a part time site arsenic?
No,
this is um,
this is our t r t.com.
Bullshit.
No,
they're just not totally,
I mean our tea will play,
play some stories that are good and real,
but they'll also play some stuff where you go,
Oh God,
don't do that.
You're ruining what little credibility.
But it's uh,
yeah,
our tea there.
They'd sketch no little bits,
little bits,
sketch.
Sometimes we have Abby Martin August 5th they have,
they have some good and you know what?
I feel like they're in the process.
Just like Al Jazeera was of moving from sketch to not so sketch anymore.
It's an evolution.
Um,
so,
so it depends.
Huh?
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
It's interesting trying to be more credible.
Some of the hard hitting stories are coming from Russian times and again though,
because the stupid American media is leaving the door wide open if they were
doing real journalistic.
It's a little like saying,
you know,
when the football players went on strike in,
the NFL goes on strike and all of a sudden you're watching guys who couldn't
play in the NFL where we're going at resumes.
But that's all you have.
That's,
that's the analogy is that all of a sudden the NFL is on strike or not.
We're doing the job.
So we're watching football players to go,
hey,
he's a pretty good running back.
That's because he's not up against Eric Dickerson.
If it doesn't,
you don't have anything to compare it to.
So our media is not doing its job.
So when anybody looks like they're even kind of doing the job of real
journalism,
it looks great by comparison.
That's a very interesting analogy and that's a mixed martial arts analogy as
well as lower organisations.
When fighters look spectacular and they find the UFC or that way,
you know,
this guy looks great,
but who is he fought?
You know?
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
I think that's a,
that's a really good point.
It's a really interesting point.
It's a,
the whole thing.
It's very strange,
man.
We,
we live in one of the weirdest times to be alive.
But I guess that's always been the case.
People have always lived in the words.
Yes,
that's a good,
and you know what,
that's what I try to remember is that the way we in general,
on a cellular level feel is the way it's always been when you kind of go,
God,
this is really strange.
What's that old Chinese proverb?
May you live in interesting times.
Right?
It's a double edge sword.
Exactly.
And that's always been the case.
And you know,
some Roman was going does Germans are so weird,
man,
we got,
it's a strange time to be alive.
And when you see things like this Hastings thing and with your deep knowledge of
history and all the crazy shit that people have done from didn't,
the cons didn't,
didn't,
uh,
one of the fucking son's get poisoned when a gang is [inaudible] son who might
not have really been his son.
Didn't they kill them how they think?
So they don't know.
Again,
the bungles weren't exactly keeping scrupulous records about these things.
But what's really shocking to us is that in this day and age,
I mean if,
let's just go on a big fucking crazy tinfoil hat limb,
if they did kill my Michael Hastings,
it's amazing that they can still do that.
Like they get busted for cheating.
Like they get busted for having an affair with some chick is threatening some
other chick,
you know,
and then the FBI is actually going to have to the CIA.
There's all this exchange of information that to me that someone can still do
that the most interesting.
You know,
when you talk about history and what could be the weirdest thing that happened,
if that information became confirmed and we knew for a fact,
let's pretend what happens is somehow it comes and we know the government killed
Michael Hastings.
The reality changes like in a nine 11 108 all of a sudden all bets are off.
Absolutely everything.
We weren't that statement.
This in quotes,
the government,
is it the government or is it a small group of people with military that stand
to the to like really be damaged by one of his stories that that's the door that
gets opened.
Right.
If this happens then everything,
then you go,
okay,
the president has to comment,
the congress has to comment the investigation and then then the big war starts
between information versus no information versus we'd have national security.
Michael you,
if you knew what we knew about what Michael Hastings was about to report you to
kill them yourself.
I mean it's going to get to be that kind of thing,
but again,
I'm not little Asterik I just can't see that but,
but if it happened it would change everything.
Yeah,
it would.
It would be like finding out that John F.
Kennedy was killed.
Here's the gunman's name,
he was,
he was hired by the Johnson in minister or whatever.
The world change and that's why the conspiracy nuts in the Kennedy thing,
they can't give that up cause like Oliver Stone,
his whole,
a lot of his world views based on the idea that that is what happened.
Therefore this government is the government that did that.
You know,
a whole bunch of dominoes start falling.
If you find out something in the government with official sanction killed
Michael Hastings,
the world is different and everybody would have to respect,
people would have to start answering questions.
We would have to start discussing it.
Wolf Blitzer might have to mention it on the news.
It's not going to mention,
I know he's not going to mention he's going to dance around it one way or
another.
Don't think we should have killed me.
It
isn't the Michael Hastings thing.
A Boon for society.
Don't you think?
Shouldn't he have been killed?
You need to be killed sooner.
We'll take a poll.
CNN poll says you can't be killed two years ago before.
Well listen to her.
Very interesting.
CNN polls.
Geraldo Rivera said did.
Yeah.
Those,
I feel very sorry for Michael Hastings family,
but let's not forget he took down our greatest fighting general.
They really say that.
Oh my God,
he repeated it.
Yes.
Well,
while we're talking about people who aren't really journalists so well,
he used to be number that he was the reason why the,
I never went there.
Now do you know that he was the reason why there's a prude or film was released?
Maybe proof of film was released on the Geraldo Rivera Rivera show with Dick
Gregory in the 1970s I think it was.
That was a new version of it.
I don't know cause I was thinking [inaudible] show in the 1970 [inaudible] he
did.
He did.
I'll take your word for it.
I was watching the monkeys.
I've watched the video watch the video of the shows.
I thought they just had a different angle.
They showed it for the first time on television.
People got a chance to see what was really what really happened and get to see
the,
I will not,
I will not eat bait theorist.
We'll play,
we'll play and we'll,
and I believe you will end with Geraldo,
uh,
with Dick Gregory on his show showing the Zapruder film because it's fascinating
because it's also a time machine,
uh,
into,
into the past.
But before we end with this hardcore history,
you got it.
If you,
if you don't have this on your iPod or your phone,
your android go get that shit.
The lady show is not really representative.
We did some different things but just yet listened to a couple if he can't stand
the one you listened to listen to and that's Dan Carlin's a bad motherfucker and
he made history interesting to me.
So that's,
you just are a mangled,
I'm a Mongo fan but I'm also Martin Luther Fan.
I'm a fan of that episode.
I'm a fan of,
uh,
was it Thor's angels,
angels listening to Right Hannity and then violence too.
You got some amazing shit and go.
They really are.
I'm going to listen to it.
And like audio books are like long tail there.
They're just fantastic.
Really great stuff.
So folks go subscribe to that Shit guys.
Follow him on Twitter.
Thank you man.
You've made a huge difference in our numbers too and your audience has been so
cool.
And I mean I can't thank you enough and I don't think you enough but and guys
you thanked me planning.
Well hold on a second before we go though the you,
but I found out I should thank my audience cause I found your audience contacted
me saying listen,
it was a Yiddish hookup,
wasn't it like a shit up.
We have each other for sure.
You've made even enlightened me about history.
It's very entertained me and the reason why people are enjoying it so much,
it's not just because I'm talking about it,
it's because it's awesome.
You mentioned it all the time.
So we're grateful.
It's fucking great shit man.
Keep it up.
Please do and support him.
Please subscribe and you can get all of the first 50 of them are free and if you
want to get all the back ones for 1520 years,
2012 or something.
And Mark Marin,
Mark Marin does 50 sorry.
So it's 12 whatever it is,
it's worth paying for it.
They literally are audio books there,
like an iTunes song is what we charge for them and they're like four hours long
and you can get it on iTunes.
Yeah,
you can get it on iTunes now.
You are a websites even cheaper.
You can't go to go there then.
What's the website?
Dan carlin.com.
Go there.
Thank you very much.
My brother.
Always a pleasure.
I love it.
We got to do this more often because people are fucking screaming.
You briefly talked about history by plan to come back.
I won't talk about history.
This and man is an open invitation.
Anytime you're in town,
you can come back.
All right.
Y'all take you up on it.
I'll,
I'll fucking fly up there.
I'll hang out at your house.
That'd be fun.
Yeah,
for sure.
The squash is up there.
Yes.
He his country.
He,
it goes to the University of Oregon.
I'm mother fuckers out there.
It's out there and plays tight end.
Um,
we're gonna,
we're gonna leave with this,
uh,
with this Geraldo Rivera thing.
Uh,
thank you to squarespace.com.
Use the code word Joe Eight and you can save yourself some cash,
a 10% off a new subscriptions and learn how to make a website.
You fucking savage.
Thanks to [inaudible] dot com go to o n n I t use the code named Rogan and save
10% off the number one sex toy for men.
What getting confusing.
It's a joke to joke.
It's an inside joke that used to be the fleshlight thing might be stoned.
No,
I didn't stupid.
It was a joke.
That's why I looked at you.
Okay.
This is a Dick Gregory on the Geraldo Rivera show from 1973 is that what it is?
75 75 1975 and then my buddy,
we'll see you tomorrow with Matt Farah.
Matt Farah from the smoking tire.com auto journalist.
Cool cat.
We're going to,
we're going to talk gear head shit and then we're going to try to do Tony
Hinchcliffe this week too.
If he's around.
I know Tony's got a new show that he's doing with you,
right?
We'll do that.
Okay.
Here,
turn this up.
Goodnight.
You fucks.
See Tomorrow,
eight millimeter footage
and they're hitting now toward elm street.
They're on Houston Street now.
They're going to make a left hand turn.
It's on the corner where they going to make the turn there that the book
depository was now this is the Zapruder film.
Okay,
so the cars are coming along now into Dealey Plaza?
Yes.
These are the lead motorcycles of the motorcade.
All right.
Now with the president and Mrs County has also governor Connally right now
before he goes behind the sign,
the president is waving to the crowd.
When he comes out from behind the sign,
he is shot.
Then governor Connally,
his shot,
he's already been hit.
He's already been hit and now at the bottom of the screen,
the hit shot,
that's the shot that blew off his head.
It's the most horrifying thing I've ever seen in the movies.
Now the Warren Commission said that all of the shots were fired from behind by
Lee Harvey Oswald alone,
the SAS and firing out the president and then she could see clearly the head is
thrown violently backwards.
Completely consistent with the shot from the front.
Right now.
This is an extreme blowup of just the president from the film
coming up behind the sign.
He shot,
he's hit from the sit here,
the front to from the front.
Now,
Jackie doesn't realize what's happened yet.
She goes to his aid and now
he's hit again.
The violent backward motion,
totally consistent with 80% of the witnesses,
which said the shock came from the grassy knoll in front until the writing.
It's interesting to know how many people is running to Raj,
where most folks thought the shots came from.
The head goes backwards in the next either side of the street.
Oh God.
That's awful.
That's the most upsetting thing I've ever seen and we'll talk about in a minute.
[inaudible].